[Music]
okay
i start these very awkwardly i end these
very awkwardly
[Music]
all right you agree i don't know i just
like i'm
i'm willing to see whatever it is that
you do i'm here for you
i'm obsessed that you're here thank you
i was scared to ask you to do this what
i don't know i was scared to ask you to
do this because i was like i don't know
how close we are but i feel really close
to you which is not
deserved i haven't earned the right to
feel close to you
a lot of people do what is that why i
think i
i don't know i think cause i'm like
pretty much myself in interviews so
people feel like they actually know me
in a way too authentic yeah that's what
ellen
it's backfiring isn't it it's a little
weird sometimes i feel super close to
you
and you also like just make me laugh and
i think when people make you laugh in a
big way they just get into your heart
like
every time i go to your instagram and i
see power bottom
it makes me laugh what does that mean
so i'm putting the microphone in so we
get the whole snorkel
i want to get the full audio experience
anyone that follows me on instagram is
very confused by that because power
bottom is v so like i'm
gabby three shabby on instagram but the
original was gabby too shabby
that's name power bottom and so i don't
know
um i'm just a power bottom you know like
i like to lay down but also i like to
give you power
so like you're cheering them from the
bottom
like a little pat like encouraging pats
on the butt
like what is this it's my style i like
it
it actually helped me a lot because i
thought being on the bottom was so lazy
but you've sort of made it be like an
empowering thing yeah i get the most
work done on the bottom
what am i doing on the top that's not my
favorite what am i in my 20s
that's not why i was shy i don't have
the knees for talking
my lower back is just not conducive to
this that's the most embarrassing like
i'm in a point in my life where
in my late 30s where if i'm like yeah
i'm going to get on top like i'm going
to like be
like i'm so young and bouncy and then my
knees kind of lock in
and in order to get off i kind of just
have to like do like the dead
bug oh no because it's like yeah like my
embarrassment yeah it's very
embarrassing you know just stay on the
bottom like me
yeah i on the bottom there's a lot you
can do you can do kegels
you can do that's what i'm saying okay
yes there's a lot to do
anyway thank you thank you for for
empowering us
bottoms yeah i mean bottom stand up
bottoms please it's also like
appropriating gay culture
it's a gay thing i'm so sorry guys um i
want to talk
about your man not explicitly not just
because we really hit it off
uh top to my bottom your power top
but you guys met on a dating app right
yeah we met on bryan
we so dude raya i met someone on mariah
okay that i was engaged to yeah i'm just
yes
yeah okay ryan is real raya for you guys
that don't know you've heard me talk
about it on this podcast almost every
time
because pretty much every episode i make
fun of john cusack's profile
uh yeah that's exactly why i didn't want
to be on raya
i call famous people out for like
preying on young girls on raya
yeah i know all those old actor jeremy
piven get off raya
pull it together i don't like what's
happening here i don't like it one bit
but i do like to talk about like what
was your uh in raya
the dating app you have a song for your
profile like it's a montage of pictures
what was your song
it was uh this is it what lucini falls
from the sky let's get rich
i think it originally was something dumb
and i was like no this is who i am
hip-hop like do what you see is where
you get no false advertising here
yeah that's it this is my lucini that's
what my
that's what my song was mine now is a
song by blood orange called you're not
good enough
and it just says under my picture you're
not good enough
how's that working not getting a lot of
dates it's not great
no it's a little bit of a dry spell at
the moment uh not going fantastic
and but um i'm so fascinated by
this conundrum of men of what photos to
post because it's like
very rare a guy's profile can look cool
it's
very rare yeah so what did you see okay
so this is how did he do it i think it's
impossible as a guy to look cool on a
dating app so
like a selfie with a bulldog that's not
yours you're like at a friend's wedding
crapping out your axe because you know
that's the photo you look good in you're
always on like a rock
guys are always on rocks and cliffs and
shit he was on a boat
were
whoa okay so he was holding them up by
the string with the like bare chest
hair hair blowing in the wind on the tip
of the boat
red trunks and sunglasses and like like
literally like
little have i remixed two pictures into
one
no sunglasses but didn't you look at
that and go like this is gonna be my
weekends
i'm gonna have to go fishing i mean i
don't know what i was
like every like after we were fully
dating i like went back i go back to his
profile on raya all the time
and i always starting to block him like
i'm like like i'm
like weird like for no reason i'd be
like i'm gonna block you
and he's like in the bathroom like like
together
but i'm like every time i go i was like
i was truly i was like why did
i say yes to this like what about this
like because also i was choosing people
based on their song too
yeah and also the music taste is huge it
was huge and i did not know his song i
didn't understand it
it wasn't it was like all j every other
freckle
alt j every other freckle oh that's
which sounds like a folk song to me i
don't know
it's not like something is that ironic
johnny get your hammer ass song
did you have a man bun in your photos as
well
deep v
[Music]
well it's not d it wasn't like a it was
like a little yeah
did you see did you see chest hair
that's how you know it's a deep v if you
see a couple pubes poking out
by the way okay so his song was sketchy
and here's the thing though i think on a
like primordial level seeing a guy with
a fish i think on some subconscious
level you're like provider
do you know what i mean he can provide
for me he can fish like he
you know what i mean okay there is
something about it
that is like kind of sexy but then
there's i don't know it depends on where
they live
because it's sort of like if you live in
l.a and you're fishing like this is not
what are we doing yeah you have to take
the extra step to go fishing when you're
in l.a yes
yeah i still don't know why i picked him
but like he's very handsome
and so like he's he's kind of hot but
like also
at that time how how do you know about
someone's height
oh what if he had not been taller than
you you know what i'm
five four it's almost impossible to be
shorter than him yeah it's really easy
to be like
it's re it's easy i've also been 5'4
since i was 11.
so i used to be really really tall for
your age yeah
yeah yeah then i just stayed there and
so as people grew around me
i didn't know i didn't and i also i'm
not like one of those like height queens
like i have a friend that's like if he's
not six seven get the fuck out of him
like you know he's not six seven so you
know like she's one of those
and i'm like that seems crazy like i
can't reach that far up it doesn't mean
anything to me
yeah exactly like i don't always want to
have my head in his dick like in public
yeah but i i i do feel like i'm because
i'm such a like alpha female or people
say
like i have an aggressive personality so
i feel like if a guy's taller than me
i'll be like a tiny little like i'll be
like your little pip squeak like it
makes me less
obnoxious or something so i also you're
tall i'm really tall yeah
so i like to have a guy that's taller
than me but a lot of times guys on their
dating apps they don't put their height
so what you have to do is just like look
up their instagram until you see them
next to like a famous statue or like
landmark
and then you have to you have to have a
murder board where you
pull the strings together
i have to be like okay so the eiffel
tower is
80 yards hot okay he comes up to that
like i have to start measuring and
figuring out how tall he is
like all of a sudden you're in the plot
of natural national treasure i know i'm
like he's like
like he comes right up to the liberty
bell okay let me measure how
tall the liberty bell is okay we're good
swipe right
i don't like it when guys on dating apps
like threaten you they're like
swipe left if you think pineapple should
go on pizza
ew like why are you yelling at me okay a
lot of people are
jerks and truly dicks and also like when
i look back at this video i was like you
kind of look like a douche
how did this happen how did this happen
but he's super nice
every guy looks like a douche on a
dating app it's i think a place where
sexism really is reversed
girls can do like corny selfies and like
be on boats and we're like she's cool
like she's fun wanderlust sea creature
but when it's a guy you're just like oh
god why is this so why is trying
so repellent why is it i don't know
there's something
nature-wise although i had like when i
was swiping i had a lot of other
problems with raya there weren't enough
black people on there
yeah and i was like towards the end of
being on riot i was like trying to mess
with the algorithm
so i only chose people of color yeah
obviously i did
ended up dating a white man anyway but i
was trying to mess with the algorithm
because there's not enough people of
color
there's not enough black people but i
realized on
uh on another girl's uh raya who's not
black that there were a lot more black
men available there
ah so whatever
how long does it take this is an
interesting what is the rule for how
long
you should text on the app before
hopping to real text
he was trying to get my number asap like
literally he was like you have a cat i
have a cat here's my number if you ever
call me and i was like chill that's kind
of how it went
it bitch
you asked me something about chicago i
feel like
something i don't know because i hate it
when guys oh yeah you can use that
microphone
we let men have voices here we don't
silence men either
we don't silence men we don't so
progressive you can speak if you want
you're not allowed on camera but you're
allowed to speak
do you know what you said because a lot
of guys i think try to be funny and ends
up just being rude like i hate it when
guys open up a dating app conversation
like why are you
single like why are you on here and
you're just like because people are like
you being dickheads like what are you
supposed to say like because i have a
terrible personality
because i'm just repellent to men and no
one wants to date me i smell like fish
all the time
because i'm broken because i have severe
halitosis
every now and then i roar like a
dinosaur
because i already hate your mother like
why how how am i supposed to be like i
cannot keep a man and i'm terrible with
sex like what do you want me to say
because i'm a powerless bottom
also i i heard this term recently that a
guy that only wears hats in his profile
is a hat fish you get hat fish
i 100 understand what that means though
i never heard it but
yes you know you see a guy in a hat and
you're like he's and then you meet him
in person you're like oh
that hat covered up a lot of sketchy
things yeah
like a weird i guess hairline yeah
hairline like
plugs a lot plus tattooed have you ever
seen people with
tattooed hair yeah well i mean we're
actors in hollywood well yeah
yeah it's sketchy it's scary i've seen a
lot of
tyler perry wig on men's scalps i worked
with an actor who
he was would go into the hair and makeup
trailer he had his own hair and makeup
trailer and would come back with a
full head of hair and it was what he was
the wind wasn't allowed to blow like
there were all these crazy things
it was like whack-a-mole to keep the
hair on his head oh my god
yeah which it makes me think like i'm
glad men are insecure about something
like we have to remember that
they're insecure about a lot more than
we are yeah and they're mostly things
they can't change dick size and hairline
and how much and height yes are the only
things you really can't change
i mean it would be painful to change
your dick size
but you can do it now i think you can
really yeah like maybe
i i think maybe you have to sacrifice a
thumb i'm not a doctor
i don't know how it works but like i
feel like you could probably just
slice off your thumb and then tape it
i don't know i'm not a doctor yeah
you're not
not surprisingly oh my god that was a
curveball
i don't think why thumb why not middle
finger because i feel like the bone is
all you really need is more
like a thumb is thicker than the middle
finger that's true but it's actually
shorter it's it's a little stumpy but
like you don't need that much like if it
were a penis on top of the middle finger
that's too much
you know you're like that's too much
you're reaching a foot like what are we
doing
i'm not a big dick person at all sorry
she's like does your publicist know
you're doing this show i don't have a
publicist
also you just dm me nobody knows i'm
doing this job
i won't go through agents because when
you go to ask for someone i'll ask for
you and then they'll pitch me
10 other people and i'm like i just want
her i don't want to have some girl from
the fucking marvel tv show i don't want
someone that you know
from like pretty little whatever
liars i don't know that's a show yeah
like i don't know i want her
and they will pitch you a million other
people and add all this rigmarole
well thank god for dms because you got
me i know i was so excited
um also let's talk about i was worried
we weren't going to get along
weren't you why because you're such a
cat person and i'm such a dog person and
cat people i'm intimidated by them
i don't see like the thing about being a
cat person is i'm a person that has a
cat
that doesn't have to be the rest of my
personality doesn't know that by the way
but you know he's a person
like i'm your son bitch because i find
the cat
i am too and everyone on the show knows
this cats make me feel insecure because
i don't feel like i can get their
approval
and i i go into like spirals i'm like i
don't think your cat likes me and then i
start trying to get it to like me and
then that's repellent to them because
they don't like when you try too hard
no i can't i don't know what to do with
a cat i start getting really desperate
and
my and it's it's embarrassing you just
gotta chill honestly you have to stop
trying so hard
yeah cause like to be fair like dogs are
fine i don't wanna have to spend
so much attention on a thing though i'm
very busy
and so like dogs seem like they take a
lot of time
my cat's a good point just like i don't
have that kind of lie
also like i'm on set like 12 hours a day
or something like that
thing to have if you're exactly he comes
to the door when i come home like he
wants to be loved for a bit and then we
both eat our dinner
and then we both chill and watch good
job good to see you
yeah he has his chair i have mine we're
all good
in his house yeah kind of like it's his
house he's probably there more than you
clean yes i know my space there so where
did you get your cat
i i got him in chicago i i adopted him
from the anti-cruelty society
on clear the shelter day awesome how did
you know it was your cat so i went there
looking for another cat i actually think
picking an animal is way more
complicated than picking a
human partner maybe yeah cause you don't
really know what you're gonna get
i guess but there's like a weird just
you also can liberation
human partners that's the point totally
but it's also there's something with
animals where you're like oh you're my
dog i don't know why
but like you it's just there's a hundred
here and like oh yeah you're my you've
always been my dog
where have you been that's kind of how
zero zero did on aaron like i went
looking for this cat
aaron is such a great name for a guy his
name is aaron purser
so yeah two ways uh a a rhymes
correct
but like he was i went in and he's next
to the cat that i want it
and like aaron is like screaming and i'm
like what's up with ramen because that
was his name
they're like he doesn't like people and
i was like i feel like he means
i don't think he likes y'all
can i take him and like because he don't
like y'all you don't fuck with y'all i
don't fuck with y'all we're gonna go
home and not fuck with y'all together
and that's what i'm about to do exactly
that's what happened and he
and once he got in my house like he's
always in my cat like always i
did get his um i did get him read by a
numerologist
okay and so i know officially he's been
my captain
throughout their lifetimes i've heard
you talk about this on something else
i know you have a friend that's a
numerologist i do what is numerology i
don't really know um
it's just i it's like well one he is
like psychic
and can see things and he does a little
past life regression
but it's he counts like i guess
everything has an energy and a number
yeah and like so he'll be like your year
right he's like the first half of your
year is a seven
and like the next half oh boy it's an 11
and it's not just like a regular 11 it's
a 22 11 or something like that
interesting like he says a lot of things
that i'm not 100 sure but like he's
right about a lot of stuff right so and
then so how often do you talk to him
about
um so he does a thing he does a yearly
reading oh nice
for me like so like your year is your
birthday to the next birthday oh nice
until he'll do like my birthday's in may
so he'll be like this is what may looks
like for you
and this is what june and all the way
back to the next april
and uh so i get that done once a year
yeah and then i have i'm that i'm a
i'm a creep i have it put into a
calendar
digitally and on my fridge so that i can
know what i'm up against it's also like
even if it's just someone telling you
good things are going to happen and
you manifest it because you're already
thinking positive do you know what i
mean it's like a vision board
dude i the one of the most embarrassing
days of my life
was when i used to make vision boards i
mean all like with glitter
i mean it's like i would literally put
photoshop myself into like
someone's arm was around david letterman
and i put my face on like i
have the most embarrassing vision boards
by the way it all came true
yeah truly all came true i want one
birthday i didn't even finish my board i
just like
i put a book on it and a house on it
and i think like um oh it was like my
face this is embarrassing
nene leakes was on a cover of like
either ebony or essence or something and
she was wearing a money dress so i cut
her face off
put my face there put that shirt on the
board
and then was like i'm gonna finish it
i'm gonna finish it but then two years
later i
sold a book for a shit a ton of money
and bought a house and so
i was like nene leakes i have i'm just
there's as corny as the vision board
seems
make a vision board i don't know if it's
like the kind of person that would take
the time to make a vision board is
already the type of person that's going
to get successful anyway i don't know
maybe there's another explanation
but it has worked yeah i mean it i
i think i really do think that like what
a prayer is just like a wish that you
actually put
um effort into so even if you're praying
oh i wish but
your body's gonna start moving like
subconsciously your body and everything
that you do is gonna start moving
towards
that prayer and so that's what a vision
board is like you don't know it but like
you're moving towards what you see every
day
in your home because you're like oh
that's where i'm supposed to be and you
just try to get to that
to that space and that's how it works i
think is this what you were saying about
your friend that was the numerologist
like if you're saying you don't want
something the universe just hears the
thing you don't
want so you're supposed to always phrase
it in a positive yeah
like i once so like i i absolutely
manifested
uh this guy a bunch like in a lot of
different ways i manifested him i've
also i've been manifesting my boyfriend
since i was like 16.
and just in writing because i used to
write i used to write
like telenovelas like a dummy i had no i
didn't do my homework i literally wrote
soap operas
every day all day and i there are pieces
of him
in a bunch of different seasons of what
i was writing
and then on top of that but then i just
the last vision board i made was like
maybe
two years ago after talking to dale the
numerologist
and after you had been nominated for an
oscar still making vision boards
yeah you don't stop after good things
happen you keep
keep envisioning yeah because like i
mean my life is
wasn't supposed to just stop at the
oscar nomination like it wasn't just
supposed the same way it wasn't just
supposed to stop but
i was like i'm good now i'm just gonna
no i have to
i have to afford that i have to have to
for the rest of my life because i have
an oscar nomination i can't work at
starbucks
but i somehow like need to like i need
to survive
and also i really like what i do and so
and i want to do what i
do comfortably and confidently and so if
that's just
if part of that is a classes or paying
attention
or you know researching plus maybe
making a cardboard cut out
then i'll do it it's actually kind of
free
because there's something weird about
getting like one of the highest honors
anyone can
get that young in your life yeah
i also like came by it very differently
like i got nominated for precious and
precious was my first audition
and i auditioned on monday i was hired
wednesday and like a year and a half
later was nominated for an oscar so like
everything this was never a plan
it's all super topsy-turvy and i don't
really super understand the space that
i'm in i just know i must be
in the right place and so it's and it
kind of didn't really
feel like it was the highest honor that
i could achieve
when i did it like i was i think i was
25 years old
and it because it never been in my plan
i never wanted to be an actress
and it just i mean it's great and i'm so
honored and i'm so lucky
no i work hard i'm unlucky you worked
very hard today
you are very hard to be this lucky
that's what i say yeah you earn your
luck
i yes i've earned my luck and um and i'm
really really grateful but i also know
that like
that that's not just everything that i
am
yeah because it's also never been really
a part of like
my personal journey and my personal you
know because it's like two different
things that i've heard you like
was listening to other podcasts and
you're really inspiring me but i found
myself
really aligning with you and and half of
what we're saying is
you manifest something if you can see it
it'll happen and then the other thing
we're saying is like
you find something when you're least
looking and least expecting it
you know what i mean which is part of i
think finding the right partner for you
i think if you know we uh my therapist
says like when you chase something you
chase it away
like if you want something so badly
you're gonna repel it it's like
repellent energy
like i'm sure you know obviously like
your talent is part of it but when you
went into audition
you weren't like i need this job no i
remember like so i auditioned monday the
next day was a call back and i went in
and the jessica kelly who was the
casting um
person and billy hopkins who was like at
some point married to lee
billy's like a legend in casting he did
sex in the city he did
like the original rose and macaulay
culkin yes foul mccully culkin like
found john goodman like basically told
like the first season of roseanne 20
years ago
they found him he was doing a play and
they said you have to wait to shoot it
for him
like he he like he was like one of the
casting directors that had that kind of
power
yeah billy's really doubt yeah but like
of course i don't know who
any of these people are yeah yeah you
don't know that yeah i've
literally walked in from phone sex so
then i choose a phone sex
operator we'll get to that later yeah
yeah
so i get into the audition and there's
like the there's a part
it was it was the audition for when she
announces to the classroom that she has
hiv and she gets really mad at the
teacher
and she's like you need to write she's
like fuck you you know what i've been
through like you know that sort of thing
and so jessica comes up she's like you
know that fuck you part you really gotta
you know and i was like i
kind of i a little bit and then she said
then i did the audition or something
and billy was like get our script like
all of a sudden things like we're moving
very fast
yeah and then jessica said to me she
said it's so crazy she's like you're not
even nervous and i was like
because i don't believe you i have
nothing to lose i have nothing to
like i was i'll i'll i'll do this and
then go suck dick over the phone
so like you're not even like there's
none of this means anything to me
i got a shift okay i got 12 hours of
sucking dick in front no i know they're
just clear there's no check so far
it's just i and i literally said to her
i just
i don't believe you because she was like
you're
the because they were like you're the
best one we've seen we've been looking
for months
like you're really changing our day and
i was like
cool just because i think people are
liars
yeah and like i mean thank god they
weren't lying to me
and like but also i think that if i
really wanted it i would not have gotten
it
i would have tanked if you really want
wanted it you would not
have gotten it like that is it's i'm
always trying to reconcile
you have to visualize yourself getting
what you want you have to act as if you
have to you know
but then also don't need it yeah be able
to let go
of something that's not meant for you
expect you're gonna get it but when you
don't
detach and have grace yeah and the thing
is like i
i needed it like i needed it i was at a
space where
i was trying i like hated my job
i had been passed over for a promotion
or they were making me wait for the
promotion
i was like fuck it i'm just gonna go
back to school i couldn't afford school
i like still live with my mom and my
brother and like
and there are roaches and mice and i
hate everything i hate everything my
hair is weird everything is weird
i hate everything i need a real life and
so i
needed it but i just didn't believe it
was that like i kind of was and i
remember saying to god
i was like listen whatever it is i'm
supposed to be
whatever it is i'm supposed to do with
my life just put me on that track i'll
find my way through it
just put me there and then all of a
sudden i was in an audition
and i was uh i was like okay this is too
high
like this is i was like there's no way
it's mocking like this is not gonna
happen
yeah it's not because like i live in the
second shoe falling the first shoe has
never happened
it's always been the second shoe you
know what i mean and so
and it all of a sudden it was just the
opposite like it was like
oh okay so
oh that's what this is all for this is
the actual plan and so this is where i
guess i need to stay didn't even know if
i liked it didn't even know if i liked
acting
did not know and i did like apparently i
did but i remember being like i hope i
like this bullshit because
this is weird but i do i really really
really enjoy what i do
and it's not it's not about money it's
not about awards it's not about
any of that stuff it's not about faith
it certainly isn't about fame
it's really about purpose it's like this
is the story i want to tell this is a
story i've always wanted to tell
and didn't know it because like i used
to be a writer i was always excited to
tell stories
always and didn't realize that i could
do it in this form
and so but it just happened it just
happened which is great but also i know
that i was moving towards there i know
that where i was in my life i hated and
i was stuck
and i asked to move out so you were
saying
i changed the subject uh when you met
your guy i was i was watching some
interviews of you
where you kind of were like i'm dating
my work i'm not really looking to date
that's not really my priority yeah that
was a lie not really
i was lonely bitch but you're supposed
to say that you're supposed to be like
you know what i'm just walking to my
purpose right now
you know i need a man i don't need a man
at all like whatever wendy is intrusive
and like when do you know i'm lonely you
bitch leave me alone dude
watching your wendy williams interview
has made me cringe i was just like don't
ask that why can't you just let it go
it's clear she doesn't want to talk
about this like i oh
god so she's like that i mean like yeah
that's why that's why
that's her bread and butter is just like
yeah since someone's uncomfortable and
like keep asking
yeah like you know i know
this we didn't this wasn't in the
pre-interview you know we're not
supposed to do
this she's gonna ask what she's gonna
ask though and so but i yeah i
yeah no sure i'm always dating my work
whatever the fuck that means
but i also yeah i i wanted a partner
i've always wanted a partner and i had a
partner that was horrible so he was not
a partner
and i i kind of i mean
really really had been writing this like
he's an amalgamation of
all the things that i wanted that i
thought was like the perfect boyfriend
or the perfect partner and i just wasn't
seeing that in the world
ever i wasn't bumming up against that um
tell me if i'm pulling up wendy williams
uh by asking an appropriate question uh
over and over again five different ways
uh um
you said or maybe it wasn't on on that
show you said something where
you were like i don't think i've ever
been in love before uh
yeah i think you were maybe like 30 at
the time and you were like i thought i
was in love
but i wasn't and i was like like my head
exploded i was like
fuck dude i've done that was me like i
confused love and pity no i pitied that
person like no i was rescuing that
person or like no i was just like
putting them on a pedestal and like just
ignoring red flags to try to make it
work or i was
recreating my childhood circumstances
that was like all the negative qualities
of my dad and i was just like dada like
trying to get his approval to try to get
my dad like i just
you really made me realize that i was
like yeah i've been in love maybe once
for
real even though i've said i love you
many times to many people
i had i was in i had been in one
relationship and he said i love you
first
i thought that's just what i'm supposed
to do and that that relationship hurt
it's like you've ever been like
depressed and the air hurts
you mean where like a shower feels like
fire you're gonna be like that'll get
you that ketamine spray and you're never
gonna feel that again
you're gonna be fine those days are over
but that's what you're doing
he's very excited he's just chilling
so hard what are you doing buddy you're
okay you guys gavin came over all right
i gave her dudes some ketamine she sure
did
now i have to deal with this going home
it makes him really he's going to be
very positive
sherry's not going to be happy i'm just
practicing i'm afraid i want you to look
over there one day just be jerking off
with me
okay calm down
keep it in your pants bud you're talking
about love love
you'll never be lonely again that's what
that spray does for you
holy shit yes i masturbate to gabby can
you give me a difference
[Laughter]
we're having a pretty good day overall
um i was worried he was going to be
bored during this but now i'm not
worried at all he's fine
he's fine he never leaves the house he's
doing well right now
he's been quarantined for years yeah but
this relationship i had was
horrible and terrible and it wasn't even
like it wasn't
really me like responding to someone who
liked me because i knew he didn't like
me
like it was it was i wasn't even
responding to a
to a warm body the thing is i
i had been nominated for an oscar and
had
launched into this brand new career
where like everything's free now for
whatever reason
and like you know i'm weirdly respected
and
you know all of these things and that
are great and
he is the other shoe like he's the other
shoe i had to like somehow i had to
sabotage my life because what it felt
like what i thought i was doing
was okay everything is so great work
front right right so
personal life has to be great this gotta
this has to fit
because also like when you're
interviewing anybody they're like so
what about you
like if you're a woman it's like yeah so
you're very successful you've
you've achieved you've achieved your
dream what about love
for you will anyone ever love you you
focus on the thing that you
aren't winning at let's like you're
you're winning too hard
they don't do that to men they do not do
that to men and frankly
when i got engaged a couple years ago i
got more flowers more calls more
excitement than any career news i was
like oh no no you know what you should
have been excited about like that was
the easiest thing that i had done that
was
that required the least amount of talent
yeah and every interview that i would go
into
like a press jungle for a movie that i
had like directed they're like so tell
us about your engagement
i was like oh yeah that's wild
it's also like the things that they do
like i lost a bunch of weight and then
every interview i directed
a short film and i was like doing
interviews for that and they were like
what we can't ignore like you look
fantastic
how are you doing and i was like so i
can't i directed a whole
short movie first on that yeah but you
want to talk about my literal body like
that is that what you would like to do
you would like to talk
about my ass and my waistline instead of
this thing that i did
and usually it embarrasses them into
being like
we'll just move forward who are you
dating let's talk about that
can we talk about the work who's inside
of you
who who wants to be inside of you
oh my god we now take a break in our
programming
to talk about pubes so what are you
talking about the days of our lives
[Laughter]
we need to talk about pubes right now
yeah
have you ever been with someone who has
so many pubes
that you can't find their penis um
not because that's the first thing i'm
instructed to ask you
i i i would say lately the issue is more
that men are shaving their pubes they
got the memo they saw my last
four specials where i talk about how men
need to groom themselves
already it's 20 20. let's be honest but
guys will just use these nasty ass
razors that they like find in hotels
they go against the grain and then i see
it and instead
of seeing the horrendous pubes that i
had to look at in my 20s i am now seeing
red bumps that could be herpes could be
chlamydia
could be crabs and you come up looking
like the girl from the exorcist just
cuts and wounds all over your face
like i got i get that you're trying but
you're using the wrong products
you need to be using manscaped manscaped
has solved that you never have a razor
burn look like herpes again
lawnmower 3.0 rechargeable waterproof
there's a little light so you can find
your way
why are you making eye contact with me i
don't need the ad the reason
oh really yeah why not because i
memorized it earlier
stop you're looking at me maniacally
let's talk about pubes i'm calling hr
that's you
[Laughter]
i mean guys in their junk guys all they
want is us to put our mouths on their
junk
i mean there's a reason it's nicknamed
because it smells like garbage it's
because nobody needs it's trash
but after but after using manscaped we
will not call it junk anymore we will
call it family jewels
family jewels gorgeous not cubic
zirconia diamond
rubies emeralds rubies emeralds do not
just use the same trimmer you use on
your face
on your balls it's dirty and not the
good kind of dirty
lawnmower 3.0 comes inside their new
perfect package 3.0 which makes the
perfect gift
for any time of year and ladies let's be
honest if you get this for your man
or your woman it's a gift to you and
your chin
speaking of smelling nice oh they have
crop preserver
which is good to make your balls keep
going i thought you were going to pick
up where i left no
i was you cut me off i thought you were
pausing for me to read that one line
they have crop reserver and crop reviver
they're products to help reduce ball
sweat
smell and stickiness do you guys know
that your balls smell like scallops
i'm just gonna say it and ladies
listening to this hey ladies
ladies listening get this for your man
get this for him it's a gift for you
you don't need to smell chowdery balls
anymore
swamp balls are a thing of the past have
some self-respect
and after you freshen those up the
perfect package also comes with a pair
of manscaped
boxers that'll keep his junk filling
fresh all day oh cute
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code whitney20
manscape.com why is it whitney20 because
that's how old you are
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code whitney20
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
and use the code whitney20 thank you
manscape for making our sex lives better
oh this is going to make you was not
ready for that last sentence why we
didn't know it's coming up like that
here's what we know about ritual from
previous ads you use it
um i used it before they were sponsored
before authenticity
you like that it has that mint tab in it
because
it freshens your breath right now if you
all wear masks you have to smell your
own nasty
halitosis breath so you probably just
got a taste
of what it's like to deal with your
horrendous
mouth it gives you all the vitamins and
nutrients that you need
it's vegan non-gmo gluten-free
allergen-free um pretty sure it's
perfect for women
it's an essential for women algae oil
instead of fish oil
so you're not like out algal oil sorry i
thought it said algae
algal oil instead of fish oil
so that you're not burping up dwarf all
day you're not burping up what you hear
this
why do i sound crazy
i'm eating pizza ritual uses algal oil
instead of fish oil which comes from the
fermentation of microalgae a patented
process that leaves a minimal
environmental contamination they're not
killing fish
so that you can have good skin 40
of women cannot properly utilize the
synthetic form of folic acid which can
be found in many multivitamins which is
why ritual uses
folate in its absorbable form to help
cover women's needs this is
incredible they've figured all this is
true
science true science and ritual this is
my favorite part of
ritual besides the fact that i like
finally have energy again
is that it's a subscription so it just
comes so you don't have to like
run out of you know when you're like
taking a vitamin and then you run out
and you go week without it you're like
why did i just do that for three i've
lost all my momentum
daily changes can lead to big results so
start small today rich was offering
whitney's listeners 10 off your first
three months try it out
satisfaction guaranteed go to ritual.com
whitney to start your ritual today
that's 10 percent off
during your first three months at
ritual.com
whitney everyone that listens to the
podcast or knows me knows i wrote a book
and i wrote about my eating disorders in
the book
and same it was but i kind of was like
after i wrote about it i was like i'm
done with it now
i released it i sent it in the world i
released all my shame
and then everyone wants to talk about it
and i'm like oh no i'm good
but i did put out in the world that i
was willing to share with it but i was
like yeah oh no just read the book and i
don't need to i'm over i don't need to
keep talking about i don't want to be
defined by this like i don't want to be
and then i felt like i was had put
myself in a corner a little bit where
everyone's like
so you were anorexic and i'm just like
i'm trying to promote this thing
like i wasn't you know so i have such a
like
resentment and i have a gratitude that
i'm able to like talk about it so people
are late
are able to see themselves like when i
was in my early 20s like starving myself
like i wish
someone talked about it publicly so i
knew it was going on and whatever
so i was like i'm just going to write
the book for like the 20 year old me
basically that didn't ever have
something but
now it's just like oh no i don't i wrote
a book about it but i don't want to like
talk about it all the time
it sort of was like it's a weird thing
well when i i wrote my book and talked
about
eating disorders there i talked about
relationships and how
you know hard they are and and
confidence and family stuff and i kind
of just i wrote it not realizing i would
have to talk about it
but then i started to and i was like
okay people are gonna ask you
people but i also like i was like i
was in charge of the things that i
wanted to talk about and so the things
in the book that
i talk about i was ready to you know in
a way like where like i get it you're
gonna have your questions
staring she's gonna ask me strangers are
gonna be like that's me
or you know you changed my life or like
yeah
you changed my life and i'm like i'm
late for my flight like i'm so glad i'm
your hero but like
like i i wasn't all i did was think
about food
for 15 years and i finally like got
through it and can think about other
things and not obsess about my body now
everyone in the airport's reminding me
of it and i'm like no
i've already thought about it too much
but i'm so happy for you that you
read the book and feel good but like i
don't want to think about it anymore i
think for me
it was just okay so before the book
what people thought like i would get
people stopping me in the street and be
like
my dad raped me too you know or
because of because they connected to
precious and i would have to say
i'm an actress i'm gabby hi it's nice to
meet you because i
that's not actually my story it's an
empathic person
yeah and it's a lot and like at the same
time but after i did american horror
story like living in new orleans we
would be like
i'm also a witch and i'm like you're a
witch by yourself
because i'm not you know like by
yourself just you i'm not also
because like the also of it like the
also of this thing that i'm actually not
this thing that i somehow represent but
don't actually have a
a real connection to the book stuff is
better
yeah because i did that shit like that
at least i don't have to disappoint you
when i tell you movies are fake
yeah i don't have the and it felt it
just felt better
and like less muddy because like when
you know cause people have been hurt
in a multitude of ways and and i
you know i can't think of anything worse
than than incest
and surviving this sort of thing and
these people become heroes to me like
for that moment
but it's also i do feel disappointing i
feel like i'm disappointing you by not
doing this thing
that i'm also not willing to go do like
i'm not gonna you know i'm
it's not that it's my choice my dad's
not into me but
it's like it's not he's i'm not his type
but i'm saying that it's it's such a
horrible horrible thing that happens and
when people are really really feeling
that emotion
for me and i'm eating a doughnut or like
i'm
on my way in to see i don't know dumb
and dumber or something it just shifts
everything and then i carry that person
with me the rest of the day
yeah because they're just like throw
their pain at you yeah and it's like
it's like i whenever and i do not have
obviously
that um but when someone comes up to me
i just as they're walking to me i'm like
i'm not gonna be able to give you what
you need i know this is
a disappointing exchange for you and
then i'm like so anxious about it like
i'm not going to deliver on this
i realized a while ago no matter what
like and i've
i've been like really really nice to
people but as long as i'm not the thing
that they imagined i would be i'm always
going to fall short
you know i'm always and on top of that
like i
while i wish they wouldn't have ideas of
who i should be
i can't tell them not to like they i've
had ideas of who i thought everybody was
should be when i was you know
before i was in this industry and like
people that have been hurt and have
survived incest like i
because i played that character i'm uh
you know like a tentpole or something
for them and that's
okay and so like i and they're not it's
i can't tell them to not do that
it's not fair because i did play that
character so whatever work
needs to be done whatever changing i
knew had to be me i knew that i had to
be like
open to it instead of like no let me
just receive
it and start receiving it and just and
not saying
like even like i'm i'm like i don't even
think i say
wow i'm so sorry about that because i
don't think anyone really wants to hear
i'm sorry about this thing that happened
to you it's i'll i say something like
well thank god you survived that you
know because that's that
that's better and that's different
because i don't i don't want to be
pitied
and i don't know if anybody else wants
to be pity like i hate when something
happens bad and someone's like
oh i'm so sorry like what are you sorry
for like i get like
angry involved yeah something i don't
know this wasn't you
it's not you know like and so i but
those are
i put all of my issues and stuff into i
try to treat people the way
i want to be treated as much as i can
but
not always can we go back to what you
were saying about what you put in the
world
how you don't frame it negatively when
you ask for something because if you
frame it negatively the universe just
hears like if you say
i don't want my man to cheat on me yeah
i mean
yeah the universe will just hear treat
on me right yeah because the universe is
not a that's not a person you know it's
like an entity it's like
it's almost an idea a moving energy idea
and it doesn't speak like
like english the way we do yeah and so i
i remember so like i showed
uh dale my numerologist i showed him
the writings that i did on my latest uh
board and it was like so like every guy
i was
into before would literally be like yeah
let's go out thursday night 7 p.m
and then i would text on like at 4 on
thursday and be like hi where are we
meeting and then they wouldn't respond
until like thursday and be like i was
asleep
so i literally wrote no sleepy men
and so like literally because also i
don't believe that you're asleep i think
we're
training guys with mono
i i swear to god this has happened over
and over again over overseas by accident
it's crazy it's happening so many times
but i think that people i think that i
don't know if they like sign up and then
they're like oh
no actually no thanks and they don't
know how to be like i always feel like
that's like
some i mean it is just like losers and
flakes but i always feel like it's a guy
who like
thinks he's breaking up with his
girlfriend and like they get back
together
you're on his bench to a hundred percent
he's like they broke up and he like like
furiously started texting girls and then
they like got back together and now he
like goes too
okay i'm gonna tell you a terrible story
really quick
so like oh my question take your time i
showed dale the thing
and he was like don't say that because
he was like just
literally like write a line through all
of those things so that you're reframing
them negatively
you don't want sleepy men you would say
i want alert men that show up and are
awake exactly
use the right language yeah frame it in
the positive
so i was kind of seeing this guy who
um uh who was very sleepy
what is that he just he was very
he was very sleepy because he slept in
his car
anyway so the exhaust fumes were
i mean he like didn't i didn't realize
at the time but he didn't like
live in a place okay so okay he didn't
realize
he's want it's wanderlust yeah
yeah a hit a sleeping bag in his car so
but again i did not know this when we
first got but like
as we were sort of seeing each other
kind of because
i was in chicago he was in la and um i
just saw his life sort of dwindling and
being like i was like oh he's in real
trouble or something
and he had had a a girlfriend for a long
time that they had just broken up
or whatever and now he's like seeing me
or whatever and
i was like i mean like they can get
girlfriends when they're homeless oh
they absolutely but i think
i think he was homeless because she
kicked him out because he like cheated
on her a bunch or whatever okay
so he like got fired from his job that i
found out about it and i didn't
he didn't tell me and i was like oh he's
being weird so i'm gonna do what i can
for him and i was like i'm just gonna
get him
uh and like at this i'm gonna get him a
a report by dale the neurologist i'm
gonna give him a neuro
numerology report dale told him
dale told him that his ex-girlfriend
that he had broken up with
was his soul mate so he stopped talking
to me
and then all of my friends was like we
gotta fight dale no i don't know
i always try to protect yeah that's
exactly what i don't know dale was
really manipulating to make sure he had
your back
majorly i was like no no no dallas is
the whole friend that's a true friend
yeah dale's the homie and then like he
cuz like the guy all of a sudden he like
wasn't returned in texas and i i'm
i'm not a double texter i won't do it um
i've been there and i don't do that
anymore double texture
i don't do i was i was i was starting my
like
decision to be meaner to men at that
point because he was
you have to have like also he was just
like he was like really shitty
like he was really shitty like would not
come when he said he was gonna come or
like not
or whatever just like be like we're
supposed to see each other at 1 pm and
he don't call me until like 10 a.m the
next day or whatever so when we say mean
to men that
what we think is mean is actually to
them just clarity
yeah they don't they're not like that's
so mean i haven't heard from where we're
like isn't it mean that
that's just us overthinking it and being
too nice
silence is the only language men
understand yeah it's not about cussing
them out
and calling their dick smaller and
anything because you just kind of said
what you said
you said you said if i have to reply
again yeah you've spoke to me
is a reply yeah exactly exactly the one
time he had like he was like he had left
his watch at my house or something i
didn't realize then he was like dropping
things so he can come back
but he like left his watch or something
and then he was like gonna come and get
it
at a specific time and he was like three
hours later i've never watched
yeah he didn't know what time it was but
i was like listen i'm going to bed
you're
i'm going to put your watch in the
mailbox so you can just go and then he
like was like no no i'm five minutes
away
and then when he got there he was like
where's the watch i was like it's in the
mailbox yeah where i told you it would
be you have to follow through with your
word goodnight never make threats that
you won't carry out i
it's in the mailbox and so what did i
say where did i say it was
re refer to your text yeah scroll i
always say scroll up scroll down
like what are you doing today i'm like
scrolling i told you already
why are you asking me again or i'm not
your google when someone's like where's
the restaurant i'm like oh this feels
like a question for google
yeah it'll work for you google is free
girl is live
as long as you have a wi-fi connection
you can just answer all of your
questions on youtube type this into
google why are you making me work for
you
there's nothing about women where
everyone's assistant where it's like i'm
always just working serving you i'm
always just working for you like google
will do it
meanwhile so my boyfriend
is i didn't have to be mean to him for
very long okay
at all um he got it though he did pretty
quick
he got it yeah but he like he's he's
just not at
all what the what the other he's
everything i crossed out you don't even
like he's the other stuff
never falls asleep like on me like never
you know he will after this ketamine
doesn't sleep in the car
like doesn't doesn't have some like
weird other female like nothing
family stars on instagram
he doesn't ask me questions that like
one i think we were like deep in
that weren't deep like maybe a month or
something into a relationship and i
asked him because everyone calls me
gabby
and it just occurred to me i go do you
know how to do you know my real name
and he was like yeah i was like do you
know how to pronounce it because that's
like
he was like is it gabaray city bay and i
was like oh shit
he's like yeah i googled it and i said
so flip the table
you like google i was like you like
because it was just it was just like
he thought my name getting my name
correct was important enough
to not ask me but to google it before
the first date come on that's the
magical man
that's the game shit right come on he
grows
the man shit right there yeah no excuse
to ever forget your birthday
google it whatever not ever yeah that's
like i'm gonna put it i'm gonna do the
least i can do
he does the most he does it like
yesterday i like i he's like not
super handy he's getting super handy
because i'm making him a better person
but like i like randomly buy things that
he needs to like put together and he
doesn't know until it comes unput
together
yesterday he built the cats like a new
thing and i can't because i was like out
some places your cats get along right
away
i'm always terrified that my i'm always
afraid that i'm gonna meet a guy with a
dog
and we're gonna fall in love and the
dogs aren't gonna get along
and we'll have to break up my cat aaron
who's three years old loves other cats
when we got darrell darrell jermaine
dupree we brought him home
he was two and a half months old and he
um he he liked aaron immediately because
he was with his like brother and his mom
and so he was like yes another cat
and aaron was like what you i thought
you were going to get
cigarettes you know like aaron was like
what is this
and he grouted him a few times and then
the next day they were like hugging
but like for a while they would like hug
each other if we come in the room they'd
be like dispersed
so like he didn't want us to know that
he liked him and now he like takes care
of him if we put one in the room because
he's being naughty
and close the door the other like aaron
will go next to the door and be like
i'm just gonna wait for until y'all get
y'all shit together and let my brother
out of his room
like it's they they love each other how
did you know you guys were in love when
do you know
oh me and the cats are the guys
obviously who cares about that boy um
because i'm obsessed with the moment
you're like oh this is
goes from like to love and what that
is because i think we've been
conditioned to believe it's like all
these butterflies and your heart starts
racing and
in my experience recently i'm like i
feel like it's almost this wave of calm
there's it's almost this like
oh we're like together this is yeah i
thought it would be a lot more like it's
almost boring
yeah i thought it would not that i
thought there would be like fireworks or
anything i thought it would like feel
like moving
yeah like you're on a ride or something
and it does it feels like you're
slipping into a warm bath like your
horse
yeah like one day i just like i think
we're on the phone because like we were
in different places at the beginning
of our relationship on our first date
he's like yeah i'm gonna move back to
chicago
and then i was like all right well i'll
never see you again and then
and then we start you know saw each
other for like another
month and a half or so long distance no
he was still there he was like i'm
moving in like a month or something like
that
and the day before he moved he left like
it was kind of i guess the first night
we like spent together just making out
i'm kidding so we just make out on the
first i'm going on a phone
that was we just make out i don't even
okay good i don't even kiss on the first
day no we didn't
first of all i had to kiss him and it
wasn't until like our
fourth date and then after he was like
it was nice he texted me he was like
it's nice kissing you and i was like
yeah i thought you would never do and i
only did i've never kissed a guy do you
think this is a
i'm asking you you can tell me is this
because i've noticed
after the me too and time's up and all
the stuff i think guys are more which
you know they are it worked they're
terrified
good yup like they're terrified yes and
correct there's a lot of like can i kiss
you can i take your bra off and there's
a point where i'm like
i don't know bitch can you okay there's
a little bit of aren't you
able to aria are we in a press junket
like why i have to answer all these
questions
but i do think they're more trepidatious
now yeah and i think he was like he
texts me after and and i was like yeah i
thought you know and again i only kissed
him i've never kissed anyone first
i only kissed him first because he was
literally leaving the next day so i was
like if this doesn't
if he's a badass and doesn't want me no
we were like sitting on his couch
and i like he he had a cat at the time
peaches and so i
he like didn't he had not traveled with
her really so i was like oh aaron has a
bunch of carriers
i can bring you one like you don't have
to buy one like this one is you know
airport safe or whatever are like a
match made in heaven
when he told me how to cat i was like
you're a fucking liar and he's like no
this is a picture of her and i was like
okay
maybe but i brought him we're just
sitting on the couch and this is also
like remember
you have to remember he's white so we
had walked down he lived like
in hollywood we walked down hollywood
boulevard which is
not even like as if you're not
recognizable
yeah and so um and we were walking back
to his apartment and this black dude
like
he sees me he's like hey hey do you know
who i am
and brandon's like he's like um you're
kind of being he's like white boy
ain't nobody talking you're talking to
this fine chocolate princess and then
brenda was like uh butcher being he's
like i said
white boy i'm talking to this nubian
queen
i was like all right i have to end this
because this is not going to be a
fucking race riot like this is selma
happening
get out of here and then we get back to
his house like he's never ever going to
kiss me now
because now he's like oh i'm not good
enough for the chocolate princess or
whatever
like and so i was i kind of knew i was
like i also didn't really know if he
liked me but i was like okay
i'm going to kiss him if it goes south
i'm leaving immediately and he will be
gone
he's not in his boulevard that is
waiting for me frankly yeah
homeboy plenty of options
he was dressed in the spider-man suit
he was he was dressed as the hulk but
like he was hot he absorbed another
homeless guy
jack sparrow so yeah but he but then i
i kissed him and it like went well and
then the next
then he texted me when i was like when i
got home and i was like
it was nice kissing you and i was like
yeah i thought you would never do it he
was like just because i didn't do it
didn't mean i didn't want to i wanted to
i'm just
he's it turned it's the me too you i
just didn't want you to
call ronan farrow
he's so fucked up and he's professional
uh
yeah i guess because it's a pandemic so
we were in chicago
and then because that's where empire
shoots and when the empire ended i was
just like kind of stuck there do you
want to take a plane
and then he like lived there and then i
was like well i have to drive back to
l.a
and i i mean like i went through it with
my therapist and everything like okay so
if he comes with me then he's like in my
house and that's like a
power shift and like a dynamic there's a
lot of people that are like almost
forced to live together before
prematurely
but i just i was like i don't want to be
in another state
where i'm not comfortable jumping on a
plane or him jumping on a plane i don't
know how long this is going to last
and i don't want him to be another
person i'm worried about in a different
space
and so he yeah he lives with me we you
know
have you fought at all we don't really
fight
like if i do something that makes him
mad he'll be like this is
this really hurt my feelings or this
made me mad and this blah blah blah and
if he does something that made i'm like
listen you cannot do this because blah
blah blah
like i i've had a lot of therapy and
he's i don't
he's not had really any therapy you
don't let your emotions rise
what's at your divorce oh yeah yeah okay
so you know
it came from like but be you know that
being emotional and histrionic is just
gonna make things worse screaming is
pointless screaming is true i don't have
it in me
pointless if you're screaming you've
lost you've lost the fight
well no one can hear you like if if
you're yelling at me i don't hear what
you're saying i hear
that i need to defend myself so i'm
gonna start yelling and i've seen that
you've lost control of yourself
and now i don't trust anything you're
saying because i'm lost in the way that
you're saying it
and i just i'm and it's also this is
savage but like i'm losing respect for
you
yeah i lose respect for people when they
lose their tempers because this isn't
effective this isn't helpful it's not
productive
and so like you you just kind of want to
yell at someone and you're
to me you turn into like you know how
like um in cartoons when someone
like uh the roadrunner sees a chicken
and or like a
and it turns into a little thought
bubble that's like a ham yeah that's
when i see
an adult screaming i just see a child
like a toddler being like
and i'm just like this feels like i'm
fighting with a child so yeah
so we don't do it like i might i you
know get hormonal or whatever or
i might like say something snappy and
he'd be like why are you being sassy
right now
and i'm like you know what you're right
i was sassy um
it's just because this blah blah blah i
know what i'm feeling and when i'm
feeling it i know the words for what i'm
feeling
and i just i'm not ashamed it's not
embarrassing to be like
this hurt my feet like it's not like
he's he's
like this is more than likely this is my
person it's so
some people well that's the other thing
it's like are we gonna break up
no like what are we doing it's like
we're in the cage together why are we
doing it like but also there's just
nothing to really break up about like
he's not out there slinging dick and i'm
not slanging dick over here
like you know like i'm not it's not and
we also really
like being with each other even though
like i'm i'm a solitary person i've been
single for the bulk of my life
and also like for a lot of my childhood
slept in a fucking bunk bed with my
mother and my brother
and the second i got space i really
really enjoy space
and so sometimes i'm like i think i need
to be alone and then it turns out i
don't
like it's just like he's just like it's
weird he's like he's like my best friend
it's i and i did not again like it just
feels like getting into a warm bath
there's no
explosions or anything it's kind of like
we looked at each other i think we were
in new orleans the first time we said
i love you but like i didn't have did
you say it first
yeah well no i told you
yeah i take i took him to get a tarot
card reading at this place that i love
in new orleans
and then and they said something and the
the guy who's
tarot reading him who's also who have
the same name as him
was like um i see like you know marriage
or whatever he's like i see a partner is
your partner and like because he didn't
know and i was like i'm taping this
entire conversation so yes i'm his
partner and then we left and he had said
some stuff like the guy basically
revealed to me
in the thing that he loved me so he left
and i was like
i know that you love me but i knew that
before like i knew
that's the other thing that's when like
guys try to say i love you to me i'm
like you don't need i'll know
by your actions and your behavior yeah
you don't need to tell me i'll know
before you know frank
i just i i knew like he showed up like
he loves me it's crazy
i think a lot of like i don't know it
feels like there's pride and stuff
involved in men being like nah i'm not
going to say this or whatever
i have to hold out like yeah that she'll
have too much power if i say i'm a pussy
if i say this
badass thing you can do is to be
vulnerable yeah and there's like
none of that with him there might be a
tiny bit of that with me
but only because like i come from i mean
like the literally the last
guy i dated like did not like me and
hated me and i also struggle with
with people knowing too much about me
knowing things that can hurt me because
i'm thinking oh like you you know that
secret about me you have all my
eventually yeah you'll use it against me
and so i have some sort of issues with
that
and so sometimes i like to i like to
shift the power
in my favor with him but he doesn't need
that and he doesn't do that
and he he sort of responds to and he
lets me like be myself like he like he
makes me still feel so fucking
comfortable
i'm not scared of anything it's kind of
nutty like it's
and i did not see this coming did not
think that i was worth this
honestly did not think that i was worth
this i could fake being with
i mean like i don't mean to but like
it's
did you into some of the ketamine while
we were looking
why is she i don't want ketamine you
guys
later i mean it literally sounds like
are you guys scientologists what's going
on this is really
overly positive it's weird honestly it
doesn't even feel
like it's positive it just feels like
we're okay we're good like i know him he
knows me i'm not scared he's not scared
of me he's a little scared of me
he's a little scared of me which i i
like
it's respect yeah respect is the number
one thing and i
i'm resonating so much with what what
you're saying because i was realizing in
relationships like
like i would not talk about like either
childhood trauma or bad things that had
happened to me because
i didn't want them to pity me and i
didn't want them to
have power to go well that's just
because your dad left well that's just
so i didn't want them to have any uh
power so i would hold back
being truly intimate because i didn't
want them to have a way to manipulate me
later
yeah it takes a lot to and i think that
a lot of us
over share too early as a way of like
trauma bonding and then you get this
false sense of intimacy because you
talked about your bad childhood and now
it's sort of like i've definitely stayed
in things too long because i feel bad
leaving because i know their childhood
trauma
and i don't ever want somebody to stay
with me because they feel sorry for me
yeah i think i did the opposite like i i
didn't tell him a lot of stuff
until we were like officially together
that's healthy i think that's really
healthy
and in fact before so like i was about
to some of my friends were like you need
to block him and blah blah blah
because like what happened is we were we
hadn't even kissed yet
we were kind of dating he did like me i
liked him but he
went to visit his dad and his dad bought
him my
book and so when he got that he's like
i'm gonna read him i'm back and i'm
creeped out i'm grossed out like i don't
know what to do
right now and he's like literally
sending me pictures of him with the book
no i'm doing no full photos
and i was like this is bananas and i
told my friends like okay
block him block him here block him their
book and bear like it's it's all over he
doesn't even know where he lives
in the book it would have been weird i
actually like that he got it later
he didn't already did his but his dad
bought it that's actually really sw
what he ended up doing is he read like
one chapter and he was like yeah i could
tell that you like wrote this like it
sounds like you and then
and i was like shit and he's like i'm on
to chapter two and then he texts me like
two minutes later he's like you know i'm
gonna stop because i don't want
to know more i don't want to know then
you want me to know yet
and i was like he's so smart yeah he's
like i don't want to read about you
things that you could tell me in your
own time and he didn't finish the book
but he also didn't
like if he had not told me that he
wasn't finishing the beginning of that
i might have been yeah shit writer
i don't know
but also like that's so much more
involved than what i do because
if i start dating a guy he's like oh my
god i'm going to read your book and i'm
like do not read it no like those are
all my secrets and i don't want you to
know anything even though other people
know it
even though it's 25 or whatever you can
go get it but like if we're in this
intimate relationship there's shit that
you're going to find out that's not in
the book
that's like that might be connected to
some stuff in the book but like it's it
was really really smart of him to let it
come to him naturally and like i was
like he's smart and again like we
weren't even officially
like dating he hadn't kissed yet like
even
he's very adult he's a very adult
is your first white guy you've dated
yeah
yes yeah i i kissed the white guy before
oh yeah why the
tiniest of dicks good for
teeny yeah i dated one also i went on a
date with one who was like an ethnic
white he was like born or something and
told me
i forget where he is from but he told me
about his like
oh yeah at christmas time because
there's no black people the like you
know people they put on blackface and
he tells me yeah in sweden yeah he was
swedish father christmas or something
yeah mother christmas and he's like and
the children run because they've never
seen a nigris
and i'm like oh well i was like we can't
do this anymore
i gotta go put on
yeah because it's a because there also
are no black people there there's no
color there it's all white people
there's no one to be like this is
inappropriate stop doing it
and so that was like i went on one date
with that guy and it was like hella
romantic he was like super older than me
we were like on a carriage
in central park and i was like you i'm
not going to take pete
black yes that's the helper it's a slave
he was like yeah he's a slave but he
helped santa so it's santa sleigh
it's a holiday tradition in sweden and
it is like
i mean it is the black faceiest
blackface you can imagine
yeah still today in sweden which we
think of is such an advanced country
we're like they have universal
healthcare
and like the colleges they're the
happiest and they do blackface in
december
like guys how did you not oh yeah yeah
now it's upsetting so i was like this
will be the last date just because like
you
don't understand blackness enough to not
tell me this story
and i was like i was young and i was
like i don't have the time i don't i
don't have the time
i'm not interested in teaching what i
want to turn even now
i don't have to teach them anything yes
exactly a turnkey operation i do not
want potential
i don't need potential yeah you have to
come fully assembled
do you ever see that movie blue
valentine yes ryan gosling
michelle williams yes and she fully fell
in love with his potential and then
fast forward and he's like gross and
that potential
has dissipated and it's like houses yeah
i'm not
going to fall in love with your
potential i'm falling in love with you
of the other stuff i have no
i'm not your coach i'm not your
gymnastics coach we're going to make you
a star
i'm not a talent agent from the 20s i'm
going to put you in the pictures like
you have to be a star already
yes you've done your work become fully
assembled exactly
and he's pretty good mr potato head my
man
home you know me
you know what i like and if you're just
tuning in and you don't know her
i feel like at my instagram stories
lately i've been posting a lot of
inside my home stories and i've been
getting a lot of comments where do you
get your furniture where do you get your
furniture
well if you ask me that it obviously
means you don't listen to podcast
because i'm always talking about where i
get my furniture article article
furniture
furniture what did we get the other day
um we got some outdoors lounge chairs
some
long loungers what else did we get after
that
we had another article shipment of the
little love scene yeah you got that like
wicker love seat it's like a like a
peacock chair but a couch
charm machine machine the charming
machine
is what it's called it's called a a for
sure
you're going to make out if you and your
i like it sit on it
i love it because when i sit in i feel
like a baby in a basket
like if you go on my instagram and you
see that we were doing these stand-up
shows in my backyard that were
cova-tested we put the article
so out in the middle right in the middle
there's a little there's a love birds in
there
people sat on it with their little
blankets well i hope they're loved birds
because if not we started a rumor
so article combines the curation of
boutique furniture
with the comfort and simplicity of
shopping online
i said that wrong so i'm going to say it
again
article combines the curation of a
boutique furniture store with the
comfort and simplicity of shopping
online
article has a team of designer that okay
see here's the pro when i start reading
the ads i can't i can i could say this
if i didn't have to read it
well i would have naturally said it
let's talk about the aesthetic of
article i'm on the website
right now mid-century scandinavian
industrial and bohemian designs they
have a little bit of everything here's
what i'll say it's like warm it's
it's very like rustic modern but also
timeless at the same time like it's lots
of beautiful oak like look at this
it's like a rich earthy shabby chic yes
but it's also
yes but not too trendy like it's in
style but not
trendy yeah it's like you you bought it
you didn't find it
classic i actually am looking for a new
bed frame
they have fair prices you can save up to
30 over traditional retail prices
because you're not paying for them to
have stores this is it
the trella natural sofa is what we got
outdoor
they're able to keep their prices low by
cutting out the middleman and selling
directly to you because there's no
showrooms no sales people and no retail
markups
so the trello natural sofa injects your
outdoor space with the laid-back glamour
of a hawaiian vacation that's what it
kind of feels like
beautiful wicker wraps around the sturdy
aluminum base that's what we got
sorry i'm distracted tell us about those
uh sturdy bases again
i'm just saying i don't know why you
guys think i'm lying this is what we got
we got that little
in the middle i'm authentic there's fast
affordable shipping is available across
the us and canada
and is free on orders over 999
articles offering our listeners fifty
dollars off your first purchase of one
hundred dollars or more go to
article.com
whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout that's
article.com
whitney to get 50 off your first
purchase of 100
or more thanks benton
you ever had a student loan have i ever
had a payment
have i ever had never had credit debt
have i
specifically from being a student i only
paid off my credit card
or my credit cards i mean i still i
don't think i've ever paid those off
i paid off my student loans when i was
like 33 they haunt you
they follow you like like the walking
dead zombies they're always on your
heels
so you're telling me at the ripe age of
18 you didn't have the whereabouts to
make a good decision on how much you
could pay back
i didn't have foresight and people don't
teach women about money
yeah they don't they don't tell you
you're like yeah
i'll be able to afford eight hundred
thousand dollars in six years
that sounds about right i'll work at a
magazine and i'll wear jimmy choo
yeah i didn't know i watched like i
watched friends where they all worked at
a coffee shop but had a brownstone in
brooklyn i didn't know how money worked
i was like yeah i'll be able to afford
that and i also was like yeah i have to
believe in myself i'm gonna bet on
myself i'll be able to pay this back
with interest it just gets more
expensive every year that you don't pay
it what they also don't tell you is that
your degree doesn't matter
but earnest can help that if you're
still paying the same rates as you were
when you graduated
odds are you could reduce your monthly
payment and save big
even if you have rent financed before
with today's low rate environment most
people can save by refinancing again
earnings is the easiest way to refinance
your student loans it saves you time
and money if you qualify earnest offers
customizable long terms and no
fees you can even combine combine
private and federal loans
so imagine having one single monthly
payment with one low rate
can you imagine that i mean i see it
with my own eyes right here
this is pretty good that is i mean that
sounds like a good deal honestly plus
the internet loves earnest customer
service they rate it a 9.4 out of 10 on
trust the internet hates
everything yeah the internet does not
give more
credit than is due ever or what is due
i would call just to talk to them
honestly how lonely are you
i'm just saying that's real that's a
real nice people start saving today
um yeah start saving today our listeners
get a hundred dollars cash bonus when
you refinance a student loan
at earnest.com whitney that's a 100 cash
bonus
when you refinance a student loan at
earnest.com
ernest like as in earnest goes to jail
go to earnest.com
whitney today terms and conditions apply
except he he is learning to do like
handy stuff now
that's good he fixed the toilet yeah wow
he fixed the doorknob
i feel like a lot of quarantine are
becoming amish again like everyone says
we're like fully making sourdough like
my fat towel yeah
yeah my friends are all like learning to
build and fix air conditioning units
because what choice do you have yeah you
ain't doing nothing else you said
something that um blew my mind in an
interview
that might make me cry if i talk about
it but you said
that you real when you realized your mom
was a person and not just your mom
do you remember talking about this yes i
had never thought about this before
you said like i thought my mom was my
mom and nothing more
yeah i think that's a thing that i don't
think we realize when
i don't think we don't realize that our
parents are just people too
they're gods they're superman they're
heroes they're everything because we
need them for everything
and we don't realize that they're
fallible that they're actual people and
when we do
it is traumatic and i don't realize
shadow like all of a sudden you hate
your mom
but like no you don't hate your mind you
dated someone before dad you whore yeah
you're like what yeah i did and like i
didn't have that same thing with my dad
because my dad all
like my dad kind of came shitty like you
know he was like always a man is your
expectation yeah like he was married to
somebody else secretly like it was a
whole thing but like my mom
seemed like my mom was the rock my mom
was solid
and i didn't realize that she was a real
person like as i get older and older i'm
like
wow so that was her issue and these were
her
issues that she then gave to me
but she still has this issue or whatever
it's just yeah it's a thing that we
don't realize
happens it's like when you see a teacher
smoking outside yeah and you're like
yes it's like there's so much of like
the pain i feel like
we feel around our family is expecting
them to be perfect and being angry that
they've passed on ancestral trauma
or dysfunctional behaviors or whatever
but like our moms didn't have therapy
and betterhelp.com and ted talks and
bernay brown and oprah and you know what
i mean yet we expect them
to be better than us even though they
have they cannot be
they don't have the tools yeah they
don't have the tools the disappointment
and the
the spoiled entitlement we had like
it's taken me so long to unpack
everything that happened when i was
younger but also to stop
blaming my parents for my current
behavior it's like finding that balance
of like going oh i got this honestly
i got this from my mom got it this train
left the station 200 years ago like with
you know my dad's family being in coal
mines like i got all this trump whatever
but then now i'm like am i still the
person who's like yeah well my mom
drank it's like okay you're three years
old 38 years old yeah
human being and like forget what am i
going to forgive this person yeah and
also the fact that you know that this
person
has their issues then you have to know
that they are human
but you have to know that part of what
they do and what they are is out of
their control
and so it's out of your control like you
just all you have to do is be a person
next to them
that's it and it's the same kind of
disappointment in the airport when
people want you to be shorter or
whatever or better
it's the same disappointment but we're
on the other side of it mm-hmm it's like
you're supposed to what
what what are these what are the
teachers you're supposed to be strong
what like you know we're kind of one of
the only cultures that doesn't respect
our elders in a way that we're not
in awe of our elders like we're just
kind of like you work for me
you exist to serve me and then when i
get older i'm just going to blame you
for not doing a good enough job okay
uh here's a little secret that's a white
person thing oh god that's your
you know it is over here you are over
here
we respect big momma that's right and
madea
and daddy fair cause we call our
grandfather's daddy the fairy
hair order
they're now nearly 70. white people just
put their moms in nursing homes yeah
when they're like 60. yeah we don't do
if i if my mom ever needs to be in a
nursing home i will make more money
so that i can build a wing for her and
have a hot like that's just the only
choice
that's the only choice i cannot imagine
putting her in a home
i can't because like i don't want to be
in a home that sounds terrible
no we pretty much in latinos we've been
asians like it's
it's a white person then it really is i
think it might be
yeah that's fucking dark like i was on a
plane with a guy
you have some dark motherfuckers
hello colonialism what are y'all doing
yeah that's
that's like it's just not what y'all did
to the natives
not the trail of tears you're good okay
like of all the atrocities white people
have done i never thought about
i just haven't thought of the ones they
do to their own parents
yeah you're just sort of like oh they do
this shit to white people too like damn
yeah the holocaust but it's also like i
um uh
uh was on a plane with some guy that was
going to asia
to do these like focus test groups for
like digital
tools for animation or something
whatever and i talk to people on planes
i'm the person that's like what do you
do i like i want to know everything
better
you're that guy i'm that guy i'm the
worst
because i love talking to people that
aren't in hollywood okay yeah then it's
like
you know as a stand-up as an artist i
always wanted to actual human beings you
know like we're we have such a skewed
idea of what yeah america
i'm i just moved here and i dip in and
out too so and i'm from new york so
i know enough people that don't do this
yeah yeah it's
interesting oh interesting so i just i'm
always trying to talk to like real human
beings and i'm like what shows do you
watch what do you like and it's always
so different than like the hollywood
you know sort of thing and uh and then
yeah it helps me learn
that like you know i was down in the
twitter offices because i was i
sometimes getting spirals about like
comments
you know i stopped reading comments
because she's
uh the people like cutting yourself it's
truly like when you want to
cut yourself or what if you want to like
if you feel like a piece of shit and
you're gonna go look in comments for
confirmation that you're a piece of shit
100 i'm hurting myself uh and
but i would say things like just talking
about like because we were talking about
vernacular be careful with the shit you
say i would say like oh everyone's mad
at me for posting this thing
everyone like how did you everyone 22
percent of people are on twitter
of that two percent generate 80 percent
of the comments
yeah such a tiny group of people and
then you get on a plane and you're like
oh did you see that like twitter feud
and they're like huh yeah you're like oh
my god
you get different news than i get yeah
because like your twitter feed is
is all you it's really just all you it's
what you've curated
yeah yes it's all you and friends that
think like you like the same like we
live in new york in la
and we're not the real world echo
chamber everything in the middle of new
york and la is the real america
and they want trump you know that's real
yeah that's real
so so i was talking to this guy anyway
so i'm like what do you do about and he
was saying he was going to asia do these
focus test uh
groups and uh focus groups for his
product he was like it's actually
harder to do in asia because of the
amount of respect they have for their
elders
if a bunch of people are sitting around
evaluating a product and they say what
do you think they'll all just look at
the elder to speak first
and they'll just basically if the elder
doesn't like it they'll be like yo
you know like that's how much respect
they have for their elders and it was
just so interesting and i just
it's something that i had never really
thought about until
my parents started aging when i was i
went to japan a few years ago
and we were like in harajuku and there
was this girl they were like all these
teenagers
and i was there with this guy that's
basically like the walter cronkite
of japan like he's a very respected news
person and
this girl had every piercing like her
entire face was piercings like
everywhere and she as soon as she saw
him
she put her book bag in front of her
face so
so as to not i don't know shame him
or something but she hit her like that's
her face and she's like she has
piercings and she apparently loves it
but she would not let him see her like
that yeah
it's it's yeah what their elders that
respect is
is not something that i think that we
have enough of here
they say that that uh malaysian airlines
flight that went down
because the co-pilot was younger than
the pilot
and didn't want to override oh
isn't that wild yeah because the culture
is you don't disrespect your elders like
you don't
override what they say you don't say
they're wrong oh well then that's not i
mean yeah i feel like there's a
there's an extreme yeah but um like
what was the moment where you were like
oh my mom's a human being
like was there did you have to release
something did you have to like go like
oh i'm officially an adult it's not her
job to take care of me anymore
like and mom's like i see friends of
mine
that are like in therapy and that are
like really fun
outgoing people and then i see them with
their moms and they're just like what
are you doing don't you i mean there's
just something about our relationships
our mom they're just so
fucking complicated yeah i regress to
being like
a like 13 year old teenager i'm like mom
like i just like it's like like time
travel
uh yeah i remember those moments where
i'd be like oh you're so embarrassing
and i was like an adult
like don't embarrass me with the oscars
yeah like that sort of
you know that thing but
i realized that she was
i realized that she was like fallible in
a lot of different ways but like the one
thing that like really really stuck out
to me
i was i was like nearly 30 28 or
something and we were some argument
some argument about something about like
a birthday party or something some guy
and like whatever
and she said to me
she said that's why i didn't what so
like my whole life i wanted to be a
therapist
i went i wanted to go to school for i
went to school for psychology for a bit
that's what i wanted to do my whole life
and wright went and that was fun
and games because i decided when i was
six but when i was actually
18 and going and my mom's like you need
to go for computers or music because my
mom's a musician
somebody in this house needs to learn
how to read music and i'd be like maybe
it's you the
musician because i'm gonna be a
therapist and she was like nobody gives
a fuck what you want
and i was like okay this is now out of
hand i'm leaving
like because i don't give a fuck about
that whatever this is um
whatever why ever you're mad at this i
don't know but you're not going to
school i
am so cut too maybe
you know 15 or so years later
out of nowhere in an argument she said
that's why i didn't want you
to go to therapy because i knew that you
were just gonna try and figure out to
figure out how to blame me for all of
your problems
and i was like oh cause i also remember
oh she didn't want me to be a therapist
when i was six
like she didn't want the whole time
that's not a dream that she ever
fostered
ever and then the freak out of like no
one gets the fuck what you want to do
when i was like 18.
and it all it all made sense
now she didn't want me to be a therapist
or to seek therapy
so that i could blame everything on her
and i was like you thought that it's
when i was six because i'm not in
control of shit when i'm six
so whatever it is that you're afraid of
being blamed for
probably is your fault but not but it
doesn't
but what that means is that you have a
ball of guilt that i have nothing to do
with it's not mine
it's towards me but it's not mine it's
not mine it's
yours and like and we if we both get
therapy we could do this
you could figure out your ball of guilt
but like i've never no
i did not choose an occupation to hurt
you
but she thought that i had done that she
thought that everything i was doing
was in for for a while yeah for a while
she thought
everything i was doing was a personal
attack like she would i
she my dad told me one day that like he
was like yeah i called your mom and she
was talking about you like you're
a super villain and she thought i was
like that's crazy because i just gave
her a shit ton of money then again
like then again i don't know how you are
with your cats like
if my dog's lying on the bed with me and
he gets up and lies on the floor
i'm like it's a spiral i'm like what did
i do like
why don't you want to be next to me yeah
like where'd you go what are you doing
why are you trying to hurt me
like you're trying to you're not
grateful like it's like i can only
imagine what it'd be like with a child
see if you had a cat you'd be used to
that feeling that feeling of rejection
that's why me and aaron work he rejects
me when he don't want me
you've gotten numb now get it i get
better
no i say yes sir aaron and i get
better as a person i like him getting
treats trying to manipulate him like
it's just so
sick so i can only imagine what it's
like to be a mom
and i you made me think about my dad
used to say something that i
hated and it was so fucked up and i i
thought that it was like fucking up my
life he would always say life's not fair
he would always be like life's not fair
i'd be like can i have some money and
i'd be like lindsay has those new uh
whatever pumps air nikes whatever he'd
be like well life's not fair and i'd be
like well she's got food in the fridge
life's not fair like he said it all
the time and i always thought he was
like squashing my dreams and like
trying to keep me small and being
dismissive
and i look back and all my friends that
are struggling
whether it's the pandemic whether it's
jobs whether whatever it is i'm just
like life's not fair
like i have this peace because that's so
and i'm split
on whether that's a good thing to say to
a kid or not well if your dad said it
it's probably because he knew from
experience
you know what i mean trying to manage
yeah and so he knew how to yeah he knows
that life's not fair he was just like
you can't you're not
you're not you don't deserve everything
yeah you're not any more special than
anyone else yes and it made me work
twice as hard
and i never thought like well i just
worked this hard i deserved this i was
always like i have to work five times as
hard and i might not even get it and
then you just keep this is the price you
pay like it just it was like
so a lot of the messages i'm like so add
that to being a black woman
well because it's yeah with the work ten
times
this is with my white privilege life is
not fair
but it's it's it really isn't for anyone
unless you're like
unless i guess if you're born super
super rich
then i guess you like have to deal with
indulgence and like i guess
problems or whatever yeah not wanting
you for you and not growing an actual
person
not having enough uh adversity to build
character
yeah yeah like we're always in wonder of
people that are very pretty and
also nice and funny yeah like because
you're not i guess
god doesn't give with two hands and
that's just what we believe i guess
where are you now on religion uh
um i had a i definitely had a stint
where i was like very christian like
singing in the worship team and
everything
and now i am i believe in
god i believe in a higher power i
believe that my steps are ordered
um and that but i also believe that i
have a lot of
power as well and on the bottom yeah i'm
a powerball for
very reason for a very good reason i
believe in something bigger than me
absolutely but i also don't
i don't like believe in hell which is
sometimes very controversial
but depending on who you're talking i
said this to my brother he was like what
so you like don't believe in god i was
like nah
if you hurt if you run back the tape i
said i don't live in hell and by that i
believe in hell it's called 2020.
it's called the year 20 we might be in
it we're currently living in it
i just don't believe i like being a good
person because i feel
better being a good person i don't like
and i've had plenty of terrible
interactions where i was an asshole i
was a bitch
and i feel horrible and i still because
the empathy i carry that shit with me to
the day i can
recall being really nasty to someone
when i was seven
and i get upset again and so it hurts
you
i mean that's if if to be nice for no
other reason then you
feel bad afterwards when you're yeah you
feel dirty you feel gross and you feel
shamed
yeah i feel better when i'm it's better
being nice is selfish
everybody feels better so that's just
what i don't need the threat of
the devil or the threat of hell in order
to motivate you
yeah i'm just gonna be a good person
because i feel good about that because
that's that's
self-care for myself you know that's
like forgiveness too
we forgive others not because they
deserve forgiveness but because we
deserve peace
it's like i'm forgiving you for me so
that i can release this so i'm not
drinking poison waiting for the other
person to die yeah
forgiveness is selfish i forgive you
you're good i had a lot of i had a lot
of
you know ill feelings for my dad uh
and i held on to it like i remember like
i didn't really like him like ever and
then
when i was nine they my parents
separated and i was like now he's not in
our family anymore
and like was very surprised that he kept
coming around like i thought a divorce
was a divorce from all of us
but i so like from that moment i wasn't
shy about the things i didn't like about
him the things that i thought he could
change the things i thought he wasn't
good at
you know i just wasn't shy about it and
it just but it continued to fester and
be gross
and like a bubbling target inside of me
and then
one day that the day i realized that he
was a person that he was real that he
was because
i said something about like how like he
was going to die one day and i was like
oh shit
only humans die well if humans die
then he's a oh he's been a human this
whole time
and then and i'm holding on to this
thing and it almost is like
my chest opened up and a lego piece fell
through it like some like
thing was not supposed to be there some
itchy thing dropped through
and that was i'm not mad at him anymore
i don't i know who he is i know the
boundaries
my own personal emotional boundaries
with him i try not to call
to cross them sometimes i do find myself
being like
hey like i just thought i'd give you a
thousand dollars like in in some part of
me is thinking i'm buying a better dad
yeah but i know that i'm not
i know that i'm not i know that there's
no i know that there's no dad for me
in him i know that there's not he's not
going to be able to care for me or take
care of
i'm also 37. i'm also 37
and so i don't need that anymore it
would be nice but i don't need it and so
in that way i figured out a way to like
not he's not a problem anymore he's not
this evil
looming lex luthor thing in my life
anymore
you're in radical acceptance of what
he's capable of yeah
and i for a long time i'd be like my dad
doesn't love me my dad doesn't love me
he doesn't love me and then i realize oh
he doesn't love me the way i want him to
he loves me the way he's capable of
doing so that is it's his version of
love it's not my version yeah it's the
best he could do he's got 29 kids
so like it's you know it's the best he
could do and that's just
that's what he's but also he had
different parents than i did
he he's from senegal he had a completely
yeah and i and now that i know i can see
myself and i can see him
if i want a better dad i got to be a
better dad
i'm not getting better parents out of my
parents i have to parent myself
yeah and i thought i would be doing that
alone and then like so my boyfriend is
very much like he's
it's so creepy and gross and maybe i
have daddy issues but like he's my dad
and a lot like he's like my dad in some
ways and the way that he's delivering a
an adult
kind of love and making you feel safe
and protecting you yeah letting you be
the
most authentic version of yourself
that's very paternal and that doesn't
have to be creepy
natal i i actually did not feel safe
until i lived by myself did not wow
wow and didn't even realize it didn't
feel safe until i actually felt safety
and i was like oh that whole time i was
just like you know like
like bracing yeah bracing just like you
know on my tippy toes just waiting for
like
walking on eggshells like the whole my
whole entire life
until i lived by myself i was always
ready to be
you know like it's like being in a war
you know i'm traumatized in a lot of
different ways
and i know peace now and because i know
peace it's on me to keep it and to find
it
and to know where i won't find it i have
another
term where i'm like my mom is a little
bit of narcissist
which is why she thought me choosing an
occupation was about her
yeah and i if i'm ever upset about
something like really i mean she's a
great she was a great mom she was as
great as she could be she was a better
mom than my dad
i don't think anyone wakes up and is
like i'm gonna be a shitty parent no she
she did her best she loved us the best
that she could
um she loved us quite a lot and
i but if i go to her about something as
an adult because now there's like all
this like weird stuff between us because
my mom was a singer and wanted to be
essentially what it is that i am and so
there's like some muddy water and some
hurt there so if i go to her
and complain like i had to get off the
jet
like three in the morning and i had to
be at work at six
like which is a stupid fucking problem
to have but i've had it once
like one time but and my mom's like i
don't
okay what do you say can you give me
money or like what do you
do people want to interview me or like
do you bragging yeah and so i realized
that
i cannot go to home depot to buy milk
that's right they don't sell milk at
home don't go to the hardware store for
orange juice yeah
yeah yep yeah and so i know my mouth
around my definition of insanity doing
the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result
why do i keep going to the problem for
the solution you're the problem you're
not gonna have the solution like why do
i
what's going on with me that i keep
banging my head against this wall why
aren't i taking contrary action and
calling my friend
or my man yeah or someone who does care
or someone who counts on me it's now on
me that i am making the choice to call
you even though you've
only proven that this is not where you
shine
you've showed me who you are it's my
choice whether i'm gonna accept it or
not yeah if you want to make a halloween
costume
that's who you go to like my mom's real
good at that like my mom's real good at
painting like my mom's real good at like
you know yeah singing or like spinning a
yarn or whatever focus on what they're
good at yeah or telling me that
um people love me because they love her
so much that's where i can go
that's that's what she's serving up but
the other stuff
is is not that's not what she has and i
have enough
tools of my own i've had enough therapy
on my own i have enough of a coven
around me now that does make sense that
does know me
that i can lean on and that's and that's
okay it doesn't have to be apparent it
doesn't have to
what do you think in terms of the this
moment in hollywood right now do you
feel like this
change is real or fake in terms of this
like push for
diversity in movies
is it clickbait is it a hashtag
did the black squares work did it fix it
did we fix it
i posted a black square are we going
through that tone death video of all
those white actors being like hold on
what were they saying
no no i will i take responsibility i
take responsibility
were you in that by the way no nothing
for you because there was a lot of
people
i saw something like i gotta go no i no
i take responsibility hold on
for every racist joke on set how many
racist jokes were being made on set
many tons i've been on all white sets
where i was the only black
or or very close to only black people
racist jokes just fly around
it's not that sometimes yeah or they
don't realize they're being offensive or
whatever or
or even one time i was when i was doing
this show
and they barely ever let me talk but
like in all the writers all the writers
the writers to be fair all the writers
were white
the white they were mostly white and
they had me say this one thing
and i don't i'm not crazy i don't
complain about most most stuff but i was
like this is actually racist
and so i went to one of the head writers
who happened to be my friend i was like
listen
you know i'm cool but this is this this
is racist this is why it's racist and
here are some solutions to that
and so but like the people that are
writing for my black ass
are not my black ass you know i mean
like it's not and that happens quite a
bit like the uh
the first real place that felt
like okay these are words i understand
this is language right not that i
understand everything i'm not
stupid i know english i don't just speak
ebonics like i understand
everything but they don't understand
that this is not the way i speak
because like every like you know
hairstylist a specialist
a specialist has to be able to do black
hair most hairstyles just learn how to
do white hair
every medical test is based on white
bodies that's right every school like a
lot of scripts are based on white words
and even by the way right now the
building of like medical robots
absolutely that there are um the medical
robots that they're building to find
melanomas like they haven't practiced it
on black skin
so that like the robots aren't even
being trained to find cancer the same
way
like these blind spots are just lots i
worked in an electrolysis office and the
the whole thing was like saying
electrolysis is better than laser
hair removal because laser can't tell if
you're like if you're dark then it
you'll get burnt because you can't tell
the difference between your dark hair
and your dark skin it's like
y'all gonna make this like what you can
do this better it's like we're not
considered at all um but yeah
yeah racist jokes happen racist jokes
happen
on set they happen at dinners
at galas they happen everywhere and like
people don't realize
what is like there are microaggressions
there's a lot of microaggressions
we went to macon georgia for a
film festival and afterwards like i you
know they showed the film they did this
blah blah blah did a talk afterwards
and then after this guy walked up to us
and he was like i
am the professor of black studies here
at the local college he was very much a
white man
and he said and i just want to
compliment you on how articulate you
spoke
and i said why wouldn't i be articulate
why wouldn't
i be articulate that's a microaggression
you don't realize it's
it's based in racism it means like you
they said about barack obama he's so
well spoken
that's based in racism calling michelle
obama a monkey well i just said it
because she looks like a monkey she does
not look like a monkey
she has black skin and you are used to
comparing blackness to
monkeys that's what's happening i mean
that's so wildly
i mean that's but i think a lot of also
what i hear is like that color so pretty
on your skin
tone i could never pull off yellow i
could never wear that mm-hmm
you know these little things wow you tan
i have skin yeah it's micro isn't
there microaggressions but it's death by
paper cuts and that it's in the thing
that i think
a lot of people don't understand is when
especially someone that is on a set
where they're employed
it's like well why didn't you say
something well because now i'm being
difficult it's like
it's like small enough to not say if i
say something now i'm kind of a
being difficult but like you put me in a
situation where i have to say something
and it's so small that like by the time
i go complain about it like it's
probably
now i've just lost two hours and now i
have to send a bunch of emails like dude
i mean like you're costing me work
i did a beauty campaign once and
they it was like some campaign for
something
and i got there and they were supposed
to i was supposed to be using their
makeup
and they were like what kind of we're
gonna put like bobby brown on you
for a foundation and i was like why is
that that's this is not a bobby brown
commercial they're like well you know we
don't have your color and i said well
how come you guys don't have my color
like because you know i exist in the
world
like you've hired me to not just exist
in your campaign but also to get i guess
girls that look like me
why would you not have my color because
this
people aren't gonna buy this brand
because i'm the face yeah and it's gonna
be a lie
and the and what she said to me was like
ooh you're reading us huh
and i was like oh no i'm a consumer i
know that you paid me to be here
so i'm professional in that way but also
i'm a consumer asking you
why you don't carry my color even though
i exist
even though you know i exist like why
don't you carry my why are you asking me
to lie for you
because like i exist in the world i
exist
and now uh all the girls that look up to
me
are going to go buy this makeup yeah and
then they're going to feel invisible
yeah i guess she thought it was a read
because i was like girl everybody wants
to go to target and get a foundation
so i guess she thought target was a read
but like it's not i love target
we meander there all the time so much
i went in like maybe like two weeks into
the quarantine it was open and i went in
and no one was there and i was like this
is my dream me alone and a target
i was like jumping on the bean bag this
is literally
my last dream it is the best it is
the best um okay i'm gonna ask you quick
questions i'm gonna not disrespect your
time too much but i just love you this
is really fun
this is like a dream any good um money
advice i always like to talk to
uh just uh money is i'm not finding the
most uncomfortable taboo conversation
any good and women aren't taught about
money no one tells you i didn't know
what a 401k was i thought it was like a
marathon
like no one tells women no one bothers
to educate women about money so if i
ever get good money advice
like savings is not for purses it's for
emergency
it's for emergencies uh like another big
thing i got was about like
the money you have in your bank account
versus the actual you have about half of
what you have in your bank account with
taxes and all that yeah i didn't know
about taxes like
any like good money advice that you've
gotten or learned
one i keep pockets everywhere so like i
and i only really play out of like my
daily like oh
my get grub hub or oh target run comes
out of just
one pocket the other pockets i can't
just go to
you know i have a system in place um to
make sure that those pockets stay full
and if they get too big i open up a
different pocket
you know what i mean yes just uh just so
i never see like the lump sum of what
you have like this isn't available for
spending
no and but i but i also get i get the
financial reports every month
every single month um i
the honestly the best advice i can give
is there is
no one there's not one single person
that you can trust
to leave a checkbook with not one person
not the people that birth you leonardo
dicaprio got robbed remember when all
these celebrities were going oh yeah
they were
like the bling ring or something they
were all getting hit look at your
statements
yeah always even you could the bank
makes mistakes i remember before i even
had someone
helping me manage i go through and i'm
like i think you guys took too much here
like oh sorry that was a mistake yeah
like everyone makes you guys
computers make mistakes even they don't
even have minds but also
people are
people look at us and they think you
have more than you need
and so it's okay if i just scoop a
little off the top or it's okay if i
just take a little
because you have so much like you're not
going to notice and like that and again
that can come from
everybody that you know from your
children to your grandparents
anybody might see that because like it's
weird what money does to people
correct it just it really makes like
shuts down their frontal lobe and they
start to feel entitled to it they start
to feel like you don't just
you don't you're not grateful for it
anyway i mean the
amount of money i you know gave my
family and stuff it's also
chris rock said this to me once um he
was like uh so what's going on with you
paying for your family like it was just
when i first started getting solvent and
i was like how did you know and he's
like i mean we all
are we and here we go just so you know
once you give
your family members money it's only a
matter of time before they start to hate
you
so just be careful it's never alone it's
always a gift because then they start
going like oh you think you're better
than me because you love me
and they start like just resenting you
you're just a reminder of someone you
lose a family
yeah oh everyone i've loaned money to we
no longer speak
oprah said this thing to me
she spoke to me very little i'm kidding
oprah likes me
but oprah said to me she's like listen
and she asked me she was like how's
money like how's that going
and i was like uh and she saw it and she
was like listen no matter what
you have they'll always ask for a piece
of it she's like when i was making
hundreds of dollars
they were asking for tins when i was
making thousands of dollars they were
asking for hundreds when i was
making you know millions that now all of
a sudden they need a hundred thousand
they'll always
just like they will always need so
choose who you are giving money to
and i say that to anyone who's like kind
of under me coming up and
just now getting money i was like my
friend ty i was like
listen choose who you're gonna give
money to and just that
just those people and don't diverge from
that i give money to
i give money to my mother
and the way i give it is i i have an
account
where she lives and i pay the rent that
way
that's how i pay the rent and i s and i
send the same amount of money every
month this is the budget for that my dad
i fucked up with that a while ago and
now i don't i can't give him money i
just gave him
i just i just went back on that after
years like just like thought was a
pandemic and i gave him money
it turns out he's like not even in the
country like out here while i was like i
thought you were struggling and you're
in a different country now
cool got it so just but the choice has
been
my mother my mother and my brother
because they live together
and that's just that i don't i have a
ton of
cousins i have hella people being like
my house
i'm about to lose my house my kids ain't
gonna have a christmas my
i had a cousin that called me with her
baby crying in her lap we'd never been
on the phone she had no because she
didn't have my number
we were not though you know i'm black i
have a shit ton of
cousins everybody's my cousin but so
they're just because i'm a cousin
doesn't mean that we have a relationship
and it was like i need
this and but because she taught also
oprah said every
everyone who needs whatever they need
will figure it out
because if i were a teacher they would
still they wouldn't be
they wouldn't be homeless like no one
would be struggling if i were a teacher
yeah if yeah yeah if i were still
sucking dick no one would be homeless
yeah they would make they're not making
their way because they think that they
have me to lean on yes i've made the
choice my mother and my brother
which is also does it feel like because
they my therapist said to me once she
was like only do it if it's self-care
for you
so i'm gonna give you money so that i
don't have to worry about you i'm gonna
pay for your health insurance so in the
future i don't have to pay some crazy
bill so it has to benefit you
in a way also exactly and everyone that
i've
that you know has asked me for an insane
amount of
money based on how we're related to each
other
everyone i say no to has always been
fine not one of them have been evicted
not one of them have
have lived under a bridge or d or their
kids didn't have christmas in fact they
probably always
had to figure it out because you didn't
enable but they're also older
than me they figured like all my mom is
the youngest girl and have kids the
latest
my cousins like the closest one to me is
12 years older than me
everybody's older than me has their own
family and i'm one person
i'm one person like now i have a partner
but he's new
he's new here but i i'm one person
and i have to afford my life and my cat
needs
things but also by the way
we you never know when you're gonna get
the next job i have no idea and you
wanna know
i don't wanna do i'm getting off you
don't wanna take jobs for money that
you're not gonna be proud of or like
you know and you need to be able to be
able to not work for three years if you
wanna have a kid and not be in new
zealand shooting a tv show like we also
never know when we're going to get our
next check this might need to last us
five years yeah
we knew this pandemic was coming when's
the next time you're going to be on a
set i have no idea
i haven't like nobody knows and like we
only get paid as much as we do
because because our whole entire certain
yeah and also like hi our job is like my
literal job some days like what the job
is
is going into a room and making these
people like me
more than the last person they saw and
also more than the next person they saw
they gotta like me
that's not always gonna work out so but
in the meantime
i still need the things that i need and
also like the more you it's weird how
like the more you elevate the more
things that you just
need and yeah
you security these things you know yeah
i have to make more money but you have
more bills your overhead just gets crazy
high when you're like why do i need
like insurance for my employees in case
they slip and fall in my house like huh
you could be rich but your bill your
monthly bills are thirty five thousand
dollars
for a month not me
okay you're hanging out with oprah
praise god
but that ex you know but it's it's weird
it's strange and i again i grew up
poor very poor like literally sharing
a bunk bed for five years with my mother
and my brother i came from nothing
i used to shop at jack's 99 cents store
for groceries i came from nothing and i
cannot ever go
back i just know i can't go back but i
also know how fleeting
everything is and i have to be very very
careful with my money
and i and it takes me a lot it took me a
long time to realize i wasn't that poor
like my friend came over to my i live on
the upper west side and she opened my
pantry and she was like so all of the
bitch all of these top ramens that's
what you i was like yes
like yes top ramen and she's like they
are 35 cents a pack yeah yeah
i don't what am i supposed to buy now
like gold
noodles no top ramen bitch that's what
it is
i just realized i could buy nikes for
the first time like i bought my first
pair of nikes and everybody had nikes
growing up
everybody i know that's made money and
kept money
keeps the scarcity mentality you know
keep that
i mean just because you have money
doesn't mean you have to spend it yeah i
mean just because you have it like
i buy all my clothes people make fun of
me because i buy all my clothes on etsy
at like vintage stores and i'm like i
just
i'll never pay 500 for a pair of jeans
i'll never i just like no matter how
much money i have it just feels
morally wrong i'm like i'll donate it
i'll do what i you know pretty sure
this outfit not that it's much but this
outfit is
uh probably i mean i guess if i add the
apple watch
it's like two hundred dollars but why
would you need i don't need what i don't
the logo like the people when i see
someone is my favorite outfit why am i
it's so
cute i need to get back on the overall
she's wearing overalls with a little
pocket in the front
nothing matters anymore we're dying
nothing bad is ending oh shit and the
pocket is very
useful what is this lipstick
oh pat mcgrath there it is see there it
is
you have room for so much stuff here
[Laughter]
this is why she's a star everybody this
is it look at that put it right back in
there well there it is
your little kangaroo pouch
um last thing i'm going to ask what why
are white people so confused about
bl why what do you want to see do you
want
do you want to see someone post about it
or do you want someone to just privately
donate
right instead of trying to prove like do
you want
do you want to see the because a lot of
it's just performative
the performative activism shit but
or do you just want it to be sincere
do you know what i mean i yeah i wanted
to be what makes you roll your eyes
it's okay so yes this is now we're
asking about it on a sunday
we're at a sort of it what feels like a
crescendo like we're not
backing down like this is this is it
feels like we've also have been fighting
for
rights in our literal lives since
since before sleep like we've always
been fighting fighting fighting
i want the fight to end at some point
and it's not on us to end it it just
isn't on us to end it it's y'all like
it's weird how we were literally not
seen as people until like the 60s we
were three-fifths of a person
and to the today for some reason we look
like monsters
my hands are empty my hands are empty
i'm reaching for my wallet and somehow
i'm moving at
super like lightning speed and now you
have to shoot me
seven times in my back like it's why are
we we're held to
okay yes a lot of it is performative
we're asking for actual change we're
asking for for
we're asking you if you put rights for
us in the amendment
in the amendment then then please follow
that through
by by recognizing that we have rights
recognizing that we have agency that we
are real people that we are not
different than you we're not different
than you we have more melanin
but we're not and we're not saying we
want revenge we're not saying we're
better than you
we're not saying black lives are better
than
white lives or white lives mean nothing
that's not where we're literally just
saying i want to be alive
please stop killing me and you know
what's not going to fix that
cleveland fucking brown now being voiced
by a black person
i don't give a shit i don't fucking care
about these
these black cartoon characters that were
voiced by white people
now being voiced by black people bitch
i'm fucking dying
i'm dying and on top of that it's very
it's so fucking
traumatic my mom is from the south my
dad is from africa i have seen black
pain
from both of these portions of the world
black pain has never not been a part of
my
life and my system and my family and it
is
hard to fathom giving birth to more
black people who i know
will suffer in the same way and i'm
saying that as someone who owns a house
and has a cat and has money
that i my life is very different my
boyfriend is white
and i sit next to him and we live in two
different fucking universes
and he didn't even know that my universe
existed he didn't even see it until he
realized
we're someplace and nobody is like
doors are not opening for me the way
they're opening for him like literally
the drivers are not opening my doors
they're opening his door
they're telling literally a driver
turner like who i i i'm not fighting
with anybody i'm not gonna argue with
anybody for my rights i'm not gonna
argue
with anybody from my space for the wrong
like people who think i'm in the wrong
line because i'm in the first class line
i'm not on the wrong line i'm actually
not gonna fight with you about whether
i'm not i cuz my ticket is still my
ticket
this is still my car service so i'll
wait i'll wait patiently
we got to my building and the guy turned
around and said you pull the knob
you pull you pull it he was literally
teaching me how to open a door because
he was and he was black
but the thing is we get the message
while white people are getting the
message that black people ain't shit we
are getting the same message
it is so hard we have to fight our way
to self-love we have to fight our way to
being unapologetically black
because from the time we are born we are
asked to shrink ourselves to be smaller
literally on pamper packages there like
if it's a white baby the white baby has
two parents if it's a black baby just a
mom
what is that saying to me that like what
does that say to any of us and you it's
not overt
it's not overt but it's consistent it's
consistent and again
i say this to say that i can't scroll up
a timeline with its
twitter instagram facebook
my text messages without seeing a new
video of some black man or black woman
who looks like me
who looks like my brother who looks like
the who looks like the family that
raised me who looks like the world that
raised me being
shot with him with empty hands
they're not a threat i can see them
clearly why do we look so fucking
threatening to white people
how how is it that we move faster how
how is it that we are all of a sudden
monsters
the thing is we're not all of a sudden
monsters you've been telling us that
we're monsters and telling everybody
that we're monsters
for a very very long time black lives
matter is not the same as ku klux klan
it is not
we have never hung anybody from a
fucking tree that shit happens to
us our blood is on the leaves that's
us why why can't you see us like the
thing is we have
so much we have we have the ability to
have empathy we do
black people we have the people we have
every one of us should i really want to
say all of them all of
humanity has the ability for empathy but
i cannot
i just can't see it when we had slavery
when we've had
the natives literally being murdered in
their land stone and we've had when
we've had
the holocaust like and then other things
like america does not
we hide our hands if you go to germany
if you deny the holocaust you're going
to jail
it's a crime they don't hide their hands
i go to other countries and there are
monuments that are apologies for slavery
for their pardon slavery
here we have well that was that wasn't
us
that was our grand like that was our
ancestors get over it get over it no
i was raised by a woman who literally
had to
not drink the water fountain that was
available to her because she was black
the the first girl the first child to
cross the color line and go to a white
school ruby bridges just had her 67th
birthday
my mom is 67.
this is the person that raised me and
the thing is like when our fam when our
people when the people that that that
give up get
that give birth to us and grow us and
give us our sense of self
they are terrified my mom's sense of
self has always been that she is
underneath the thumb of whiteness
that she'll never aspire there same
thing with my father
how how would they ever
how would they ever be able to tell me
that i'm good enough when they know that
i'm not
they know that i'm not they know that
i'm not they know that i'm gonna have to
fight they know that i'm gonna have to
be ten
times better than everyone else because
in black i think that's just
it's such a shitty thing that we have to
give to our children
so yeah i mean it's great that jenny
slate
stepped down i guess from big mouth
but like and i'm so glad the black
actress has now got that job i'm so glad
but um i'm still very very scared to
reach for my wallet
when a cop stops me in my car because my
car is too nice for my black has to be
driving
i'm still very very upset when i sit
next to my boyfriend i see him get
treated like a person and me
like shit and i'm famous
i'm the important one nobody knows who
he is but
but it's i mean like even if i'm it's
white men are celebrities wherever they
go it's crazy celebrities it's
crazy what they like
it's crazy it's i mean i know that's a
lot but it's a
and i i know that i tend to talk about
being black a lot and it's
i'm not obsessed with being black being
black is obsessed with me everything
that i do
every store i walk into every outfit i
put on
every like shades or like i can't wear a
hood because i might be
too threatening or whatever you know
it's it's it's
always this or i have to have double
thinking i have to have double
consciousness i have to think for myself
and i also have to think of how you will
receive me
will you be threatened or will you be
belittling
like what do i look like to you i have
to figure that out before i say hi
i do and at the sort of like not the
beginning the middle like i i talk
about i talk like this about blackness
and whiteness
everywhere i do because it's
because it's just it's a safety issue
everything's a safety issue
and my boyfriend one time was like you
talk a lot of shit about white people
about white women and i was like i'm not
talking to you anymore
i like shut down for the night and then
the next day i showed them in her while
they are but like i the next day i
showed him a clue
like uh the five heartbeats i made him
like watch this like
robert townsend movie where like it's a
band they're black and
it's like said in the 60s and they're
stopped by cops that make them sing and
like throw their shit around and he's i
was like you see this is what we go
through and he's like you think i
haven't been i was like no no
you're not understanding the reason why
i taught like i live in a different
universe than you
he and i pointed out like remember this
remember that remember this remember
this
he's like yeah i go this if you want
children with me that's the world
they're going to live in
they'll be light-skinned but they will
never have your privilege
you will never be able to give our
children your privilege their lives will
align more like
mine and i'm fucking terrified and i
don't want to give that to a child but
i'm not going to have a choice
white people don't ever have to have the
conversation with their children
like that like you know white people
don't really know that they're white
until
college or something or something like
this happens you know how i know i'm
black
i knew i was black because when i was
five years old you know when you're like
in kindergarten you have to like hold
hands and it's boy girl boy girl
and size order so i was matched with a
little boy who
whose name was brandon oddly enough and
brandon would never hold my hand
at best he would grab my sleeve and he
would get in trouble like literally sent
to the principal's office he was dead
set against not
holding my hand i didn't really care i'm
five they're fruit snacks what do i give
a shit
until february february is black history
month we all go
to the auditorium he holds my sleeve the
way we always do
we watch a documentary about dr martin
luther king
on the way back brandon takes my hand
for the first time ever
been in school since september is
february he's taking my hand and i go
you weren't holding my hand because i'm
black he says yeah but now i know
thanks to dr martin luther king that
you're not garbage i'm five years old
and i know that because i'm black i'm
seen as garbage
that's what i have to give to my
children and they're saying there's
millions and i've done it i really have
i've done like the social experiment
where i've asked my white friends
asked my puerto rican friends asked my
black friends how old were you when you
realized you were
your race and consistently with
blackness it's always yeah four because
we were in the store and my mom uh
this white dude called her a nigger
because he called her nigger because she
wouldn't let him in front of her
or like yeah um this one time i was at
my friend's house and i was like three
and we were having a sleepover and she
like tried to rub off my skin she was
like you should take a bath because she
thought that my skin was dirt
that's like these are not great
experiences and so what that's what i
mean when i say we have to fight to
self-confidence we have to fight to be
being unapologetically black
unapologetically who we are i'm not
trying to be blackly black like i'm not
trying to do that
i have to because i'm being attacked i
have to fight back with all of my
blackness because you
because it's trying to be stomped out
and erased
yeah and i just think that you know it's
really great that everybody put up that
black picture
on instagram that was so nice of you
that was so fucking kind it was so great
of every white actor to make that
weird i'm sorry video that was so sweet
follow that shit up with actions or shut
the fuck up and get on my face though
and that's that on that that's out on
that
i love you i'm sorry if it was a lot no
it's
i'm sorry i know that was a lot i'm i'm
just trying so hard to not have any
emotion
and center myself as a white woman i
will my
instinct is to make this hard on me
and i tried so hard to not be like
this is hard on me but this is a racism
is a white problem
and we've talked about on the show all
the time it's not it's not black
people's problem to solve this
if black people could have solved it
they would have so it would be fixed
it's a white person problem it's between
white people and white people
and it's not i'm gonna go ask my black
friends how to solve this
they're it's our it's we they're like we
don't know you guys
i don't know we don't know this seems
like your problem
you're the one that's racist we don't
understand why you're trying to vote
instead of stay afloat that's it like i
don't know
so so everyone stop asking black people
to solve this for you
read so you want to talk about race read
that book it's sold out which is kind of
exciting but ordered on kindle
um we talk about that all the time and
yeah the black squares
aren't enough antebellum
is it out it got pushed yeah it was
supposed to be out in april
it's pushed to september 18th so it will
be out on
friday fantastic yeah antebellum
antebellum
the trailer like this is a must watch
it's a real it was really really fun to
make it's
incredibly um gripping it's gripping and
i'm in it's sort of
it sort of feels like three different
movies i'm in a different movie
than is mostly in the trailer and so
it's
um it's really really interesting it is
absolutely a must-see
you must see it producers of get out
when i was watching it i was like okay
this is going to blow my mind i know it
yeah i think it's going to be i really
think it's going to be a game changer
yeah for sure and it's also like really
really beautiful shot bushrans the
directors
are incredible writers and this also the
the concept of the film came through a
dream one of them had a nightmare
and then the next day the other they
were like let's write this down
and then and it became this film and i'm
very proud of it
and i can't wait for people to see it
because it's you will have like a
very visceral reaction to it do a gabby
weekend on the 18th
come as you are which is a little more
of a comedic performance yeah
i got to wear overalls and someone who's
i look i have nothing but amazing things
to say about kevin i love her
i admire her she isn't the best driver
uh so you know that if she's she's
driving a car a lot in this movie that's
how good of an actor she is
i actually i actually thought she was
she was that was deserving of an oscar
nomination
you looking like you can drive because
she has to drive a lot of movies i did
drive
yeah yeah a lot of and i kept telling
them i was like i better get my license
then huh
they were like wait though for real can
you can you drive i just never
new yorkers i'm sorry it's the one thing
you guys can't do
i didn't get my license i was like 30.
that's crazy
but i'm very unexperienced i shouldn't
be driving i think you took out a couple
bushes when you came
up yeah now that i'm thinking back to it
i don't always
do that it's interesting that i did it
here
yes i did as soon as you came in i was
like oh there we go
first of all i kind of feel like you
made a mistake putting in those bushes
and rocks
by the way that's not wrong they are
poorly placed thank you
i said that i had a feeling it wasn't
seven feet away from the driveway how
dare i
think that that was inappropriate yeah
gabby three
shabby gabby three shots abby three
shabby um
her instagram brings me so much joy i
love you i always end these very
awkwardly
so if there's anything else else you
wanna say go for it but otherwise i love
you
um i guess if you think i'm smart or
whatever
then you could read my book this is just
my face
try not to stare i wanted to name it um
i wanted to name it after like a biggie
quote um
i think it was however i stayed coogie
down to the side
that's what i wanted and they were like
well those are biggie's words not yours
and i was like
but it's called this is just my face
trying not to stare i wrote it myself
and it um
it's kind yeah it's a lot but it's so
funny
i describe exactly how to suck dick
through a phone
so if you need that skill it's pear and
quarantine we need that more than ever
right now because we can't see each
other okay
so one day i will next episode next
episode we'll do a class
do you ever see that angel lady who like
has the dick
orange
god bless her and her job that's the
same bless her heart
i love you thank you so much for doing
this what a treat
thank you what a just dream
i love you bye guys don't write
[Music]
elephants
you